[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-We wouldn't be where we are
at Google without you, the
developer community.
Since 2005, we've made dozens
of APIs and tools
available to you.
Then you went out and
built marvels.
Now with so many creations, we
think there's a better way for
them to work together, because
there are a lot.
So we did some spring cleaning,
then asked you how
we could do it better.
We used your ideas to begin
building a single place for
all of the developer resources,
tools, events, and community.
And all that together
looks like this.
Developers.google.com.
But it's more than
just a logo.
It's a symbol for all the
amazing work you do in the
world and how you
work together.
Soon you can find tools, get
ideas, and connect with others
all in one place, then
get down to business.
Collaboration and coding power
that creates magical solutions
with a universal language, so
you can take that mass of code
and blow minds.
For reals.
So kick off your shoes and
explore all the ways you can
connect, because it's not just
about code, it's about you.
Then start building, because
together, there's no telling
what we'll create next.
Developers.google.com.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MALE SPEAKER: Hello.
And thank you for coming to
our Lightning Talks today.
I just have a couple things
to say as we get started.
We have this agenda for you.
So we're going to start out with
Android, go through the
whole gamut, and
end up at Maps.
And one thing I wanted to
mention before we got started
is that there is a whole
bunch of Google
stuff going on today.
So we've got the Lightning Talks
today, but we have all
these other houses going with
Maps, and Developers, and
Android, and I really recommend
you check out all of
these things.
And if you forget this map, a
lot of us are wearing these
sweatshirts.
And it won't be creepy, just
go up and look at where you
need to go.
There's also this URL that'll
give you the maps and all the
other talks that are going on
by Googlers or at the Google
Developer Houses.
Thank you so much.
And I'd like to welcome up
Trevor, who's going to begin
by talking about Android,
Android apps should look like,
and where you can go
to build them.
TREVOR JOHNS: All right.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Trevor Johns, and
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer with the Android
Team at Google.
And today, I'm going to be
talking about Android user
interface design, and
specifically what we've done
with the last few releases of
Android with the Holo UI.
So we're going to start out,
give you a brief tour of where
we've gone in the past, how
Android's evolved, the changes
we've made, why we've made them,
and what they mean to
you as an Android
app developer.
So let's go ahead and step in
our time machine here, and
we're going to roll all
the way back to
Android 1.5, Cupcake.
So for those of you who are
keeping score, this was
released roughly in the era of
the G1, one of our first
releases, back in 2009.
Technically it wasn't our
first release, that was
Android 1.0, but it looked
pretty much the same.
And if you're using Android
today, it should be familiar,
you have your App Launcher, you
have your Icon Drawer, and
we opened up a Settings App
here just as a demo.
And you can see that there's
this little drawer you had to
pull up manually, we have this
big, bulky search widget on
the desktop.
The Settings App, you sort of
get this sort of ugly wall of
text with these down chevrons
that go somewhere down, I'm
not sure where Down means.
And that was Android.
Sort of a rough start,
but we'll get there.
So let's move forward
one version.
This is Donut now, released just
a short time later, and
not much has actually changed.
We've gone and cleaned up that
big, bulky search widget, it's
a little more streamlined now,
but not too many other changes
there that are really notable,
at least as far
as the UI is concerned.
So then we're going to take
one more step forward to
Android 2.0, that's Eclair.
And this release is notable
because this is the one that
came out with the
Motorola Droid.
We did a lot of work to go and
clean up the UI here, so icons
are a little bit more
streamlined, the Settings App
is actually not a giant wall of
text, we've gotten rid of
those confusing chevrons.
The App Launcher is still more
or less the same thing,
though, you have the store you
pull up manually, some carbon
fiber texter there in the
background, and that was what
we released there
with the Droid.
Take one more step forward
here, and get to Froyo,
Version 2.2.
And this one is probably where
you see the most changes.
We've actually gone and removed
the drawer that you
actually had to go and swipe
up with an App Launcher
button, added a set of Quick
Actions there at the bottom to
go and pull up the phone and the
browser, which are pretty
common actions on a smartphone,
and we added
System-wide Search, so you'll
notice that Search widget's
changed just a little
bit, too.
Settings App still looks
more or less the same.
You still have this gray bar at
the top with this App Name,
navigation hasn't
changed much.
And that was probably, to date,
the biggest change to
the Android UI we've seen.
And then one last step forward,
which was Android
2.3, Gingerbread.
And you'll notice the biggest
change here is we sort of made
the UI a little bit darker, this
little widget we added on
the desktop to sort of give
you a tutorial has changed
just slightly, made it a little
darker, the Quick
Actions at the bottom have
changed, the Notification Bar
has changed.
Still the same Settings App,
still the same Launcher,
pretty much.
And so that was our previous
releases of Android.
That's where we've come to
up until fairly recently.
So when we were building
Honeycomb, we took a step back
and said, well, we've had the
same look since the beginning.
What can we change?
There's a lot of wasted screen
real estate with buttons, a
lot of space taken up by these
big, bulky text fields, and it
sort of felt inspired
by a desktop OS.
And you have this magical pane
of glass in front of you, and
there's so much more
you can do.
It can be this tactile
experience.
You can go and get rid of all
these desktop metaphors and
sort of come up with a
brand new experience.
And, like I said, we haven't
really changed that much.
There was that change with 1.5,
but it was more of an
incremental change, it wasn't
really revolutionary.
We also noticed that there's
a lot of inconsistency.
Android, of course, allows
device manufacturers to go and
modify the OS, to go and
edit and to add some
distinctiveness to it.
But the feedback we heard from
a lot of designers was if you
go and change the text color,
if you change the selection
color, if you change the way a
List View behaves, the way
Overscroller works, and you're
really going for that picture
perfect UI, when these things
change out from under you, it
makes it hard to go and make
your app look beautiful.
So we took all this feedback,
and we put it together and we
got to what we call Holo,
our holographic UI.
So going back to 2.3 here,
let's take one more step
forward, and this is the
face of Android today.
Still the same metaphors you're
sort of familiar with
as far as having an App
Launcher, right?
I mean, there hasn't been that
much that's changed there.
But the bigger changes are
a little more subtle.
If you look at the Search
Widget, you'll notice it's a
lot more minimalist. We've added
these blue futuristic
highlights everywhere, organized
the Settings App
finally so it actually makes
a little bit more sense to
scroll through.
And then there's also this space
at the top of the screen
that's reserved for what
we call the action bar.
And we'll go into that in a bit
more detail, but that's
actually pretty important.
So this is Holo.
One release for all devices,
whether or not it's a tablet
or a phone.
And we really have gone through
and we've taken a look
at everything in the phone,
whether or not it's how a
dialog appears, how a List View
behaves, how you scroll
through your media, and asked
ourselves what assumptions
we've been making
for this design.
And this goes all the way down
to the Widget Toolkit.
So this is the selection of most
of the controls that come
with the SDK, of course,
you can add more.
The big one there is probably
the Text Input Fields, and you
can actually barely see
them on the screen.
It's sort of up there in the
upper right, and it's actually
just a line.
And I'll show you a screen shot
of that in a moment, but
actually, let's go right
there right now.
So on the left is the Email App
in Gingerbread, and on the
right is the Email
App in Honeycomb
and Ice Cream Sandwich.
And you'll notice, we've really
just reduced it to a
sheet of paper.
Of course, you still need your
Text Fields to address the
email, give it a subject,
actually compose.
But the UI sort of fades into
the background and brings your
content front and center so the
users can focus on their
creativity and not on what
their phone is trying to
impose as far as the
UI's concerned.
So we basically have three
design principles that
underlie Holo.
And we wanted a UI that felt
enchanting, that simplified
users' lives, and that made
them feel amazing and
empowered because of that.
So let's talk about those in a
little bit more detail, give
you a quick tour through
the some of the
design highlights here.
So we wanted to be delightful.
There's lots of visual
flourishes sprinkled
throughout the OS.
When you're scrolling left or
right on the Home Screen and
you hit one end of the screen,
this pane of light will sort
of pop out from the screen
for just a second.
It's a very subtle effect, but
it gives your phone a bit of
personality, makes it feel a bit
more fun, makes you feel
like it has a bit more
substance, that you're
actually working with this
physical interface
inside of the phone.
Sort of extending from that idea
of a physical interface,
objects behave as actual objects
rather than buttons.
If you have an icon and you
drop it on top of another
icon, what do you expect
should happen?
They should stack.
Well, that's exactly
what happens.
And so little things like
that are found all
throughout the OS.
Personalization has always
been an important part of
Android, it still is.
We want the user to feel like
their phone belongs to them,
so of course, it starts with
things like setting your
background, being able to go
and adjust the behavior of
your phone, add widgets
everywhere,
make the phone yours.
On the other hand, the phone
will get to know you and
personalize itself
automatically.
So as you're browsing around
the web, and say you go and
visit Wikipedia a lot.
Your phone will, of course,
save that in its local
history, and then later on, when
you go and try and do a
system-wide search, it'll check
that history and start
adding auto-complete suggestions
for Wikipedia,
even though you're not
in the browser.
So the next topic there,
simplifying your life.
Actually, let's move to
the next screen here.
So first things first, we want
to go and keep the dialogues
nice and simple, wizards
nice and simple.
When you first turn your
phone on, we have this
initial setup process.
So as an example here, one of
the screens asks you to go and
set up a Google account.
And we keep the text there
brief, and when you actually
go to sign up for the account,
it's just a one-page
form you fill out.
Just as an example there, but
throughout the system, we've
gone and reevaluated all of our
dialogs, trying to figure
out where we were being too
verbose, not saying enough,
and kept it basically the bare
minimum we could while still
being informative.
Pictures and these graphical
UIs are a big part of Holo.
We sort of call this like a
Magazine UI, so big, high
resolution, vibrant pictures
right there in
front of your screen.
And so this is the Dialer App.
When you launched Dialer App in
the past, it used to give
you this whole list view of
contacts, and you could scroll
through, and eventually,
you'd find who
you're looking through.
You could star people, add
them to the Quick List.
We found that it makes it a lot
quicker if you just have a
picture right there.
If I want to call Mattias and I
open my phone, well there he
is in the upper left hand
corner where I can
just click on him.
I don't actually have to go
through and read everything.
And so pictures are a lot
faster than words.
We try and use these high
resolution images throughout
the UI whenever we can.
We also try and do the right
thing automatically.
So we've added a feature in
Android Four, Ice Cream
Sandwich, called Android Beam.
And when you take two phones and
you hold them next to each
other, if they have an NFT
antenna, they'll detect that
the other phone is
in proximity and
enter the Share Mode.
You can then go and tap on
whatever content is on your
screen, and it'll send it
over to the other phone.
So we're using this contact
sensitivity to go and just
automatically throw the user
into the Share Mode so that
the action they most likely want
to perform, since they've
put their phones next
to another phone, is
just one tap away.
Of course, you still want to
leave that final act up to the
user and not do everything for
them, but just get them into
the right position so that
they're ready to do that.
Navigation is, of course,
important.
We've always had this concept
of a Back button on Android.
We've got and extended that a
bit more with the Action Bar.
I'll go into that in a bit more
detail in a moment here.
Also, we've gone and taken the
most commonly used actions and
pulled them out of
the Menu Bar.
In fact, the Menu Bar is
pretty much [INAUDIBLE]
at this point.
If you target your app for
Android Three or above, so
anyone running Holo, we actually
remove the Menu
button from the screen and
place all of the old Menu
commands up in this
Action Bar.
And as a developer, you could
pick whether or not something
should be displayed right there,
one click away, at the
top of the Action Bar, or we
still do have an Overflow Menu
where you can hide the less
commonly used actions.
But the really important actions
should be right there,
one click away at all times, and
your phone should go and
adjust its UI to what
you're doing so
those are always there.
And I'll give you some more
examples of that in a moment.
Also going off of navigation,
consistency is important.
The Action Bar that we've added
does a lot towards that.
So we have examples here
from Maps, Inbox,
and the Gallery App.
And you'll notice that even
though they are very different
apps, they look different.
A Map View looks a lot different
than a Gallery View
looks a lot different
than your email.
The navigation looks the same
in all of those, and that's
intentional.
And we've provided the tools
to go and do that for app
developers anywhere
in the system.
And if you're a long-time
Android user, notifications
are of course a very important
part of that experience, we've
had that since the beginning.
But just to go and reiterate,
we want to go and make sure
that whenever there's an
important event that occurs,
of course, since it's important,
you want to let the
user know, but make sure that
you only interrupt them if
it's important.
And if it's not important, we
go and tuck it away so that
users can respond to that
notification later.
So we bring things up, give them
a chance to respond, and
then let them deal with things
on their own time, so you
don't get any big, bulky dialogs
that come up and stop
the user from what they're
trying to do.
So on this last part about
empowering the user and making
them feel amazing, we've added
lots of gestures throughout
the system that let
you go and--
basically, they're tricks that
let the user pull something
off with some gesture, some
action, and do it without
having to push a button.
We're trying to remove as many
buttons from the UI as we can.
And gestures are always a little
tricky because you can
put up a little tool tip and
tell them, but most of the
time, they're not pushing
something
that's labeled there.
So once you go and perform some
gesture, we want to make
sure that it works throughout
the system.
Once you've learned in Gmail
that you can swipe left and
right between your email
messages, you'll discover oh,
you can do the same thing in
Google Play, you can swipe
left to right between categories
in the App Store.
You can also go into the Google
Plus App and do the
same thing and switch
between your own
circles and people nearby.
Dialogs, we've gone and cleaned
those up again, made
sure that they're
actually useful.
Rather than just saying that
there's an error that's
occurred and taking you onto the
Support Page, we try and
give you the text you need to
make sure you can respond to
it and actually resolve
the situation.
There's little bits of visual
encouragement sprinkled
throughout the system.
So as you're going and dragging
icons around, we
overlay this grid and put this
little shadow of the icon that
sort of jumps around as you
drag your icons around.
So even if you've never used
an Android device before,
you'll immediately know that
these devices are going to go
and snap to a grid.
And finally, this is less of
a UI issue and more of a
functionality issue, but apps
should be smart, and they
should do the heavy lifting
for the user.
If you have a smartphone in
your pocket, it should be
smart, right?
So it's little things.
If you're in the Camera App,
you should automatically
adjust white balance,
you should
automatically set focal points.
Sure, give the users a way to
go and set it if they want,
but by default, you should
just go and do everything
automatically.
Which also gets to the next
point here, which is you
should make the important things
fast. Again, if you're
in the Camera App, the
most important
thing is taking a picture.
If you press that Shutter
button, you should take a
picture immediately.
So we've even gone so far as
to go and add zero-second
shutter lags.
From the moment you press that
button, the photo is
immediately saved to disk and
there's no delay while you're
waiting for the shutter to fire
and for it to find the
focal point.
It's instant.
So as an Android app developer,
what does all of
this mean to you?
So we've gone and put together
a collection of design
patterns that you can use.
And the most important one, if
you haven't heard me mention
it a dozen times already,
is the Action bar.
This is the roughly 50 pixels,
I can't remember the exact
number, of space at the top of
your screen that's reserved
for the most important
navigational elements.
And it's broken up into
three sections.
You have an App icon, which
tells you where you are.
Typically, this is going to be
your own application's icon,
but you can change it, if you're
in a document, make it
look like you're docked,
things like that.
You have View Details, this is
things like navigational tabs.
And then you have your Action
buttons, which tell the user
what they can do.
And this can either be the
Overflow menu, where you put
the less commonly used actions,
like I said, you can
bring those actions front and
center, just place them there.
You can even add custom views,
things like search widgets.
Basically, anything the user
wants to do commonly should be
part of that Action Bar.
It's also contextual.
So as you start making
selections, we actually will
swap that Action bar out, flip
it around, and give you a
completely different
set of commands.
If you're in email, normally the
first thing you'd want to
do is compose a new message.
Once you start selecting
messages, it's not likely
that's what you want
to do anymore.
Most likely what you want to
do is something related to
organization.
You're going to want to archive
your messages, or
you're going to want to go and
maybe mass delete them if
they're all spam,
Heaven forbid.
So as soon as you go and enter
this different mode, the phone
will go and adapt and place you
in the right context for
whatever it is that you're
most likely to
going to want to do.
Navigation.
I mentioned that there is this
Back button, and then we've
added an initial Back command
up to the Action bar.
So the Back button, which
has been there since the
beginning, provides temporal
back navigation.
So if I'm in my web browser and
I click a link that takes
me to the Google Play Store,
when I click Back, it's going
to take me back into the
browser, because that's the
last thing I did as far
as my sequence of
events on the phone.
But what we discovered is
sometimes users actually want
to go and once they navigate
into that other app, they want
to go and explore more there.
They want to get back to the
home page of that app.
And so the other Back button is
a hierarchical Back button.
It'll take you back up within
the navigational tree of the
current application.
So we actually call it Up.
So that's actually, if you think
of a tree, you're going
back up to the root
of that tree.
So if I'm in Google Play and I'm
in an App Detail page and
I click Up, it'll start taking
me back to the Google Play
main screen.
And so that's a really important
navigational pattern
that you'll find all throughout
Android now, and
it's really important to go and
make sure your apps are
updated to go [INAUDIBLE]
of that.
Multiple pane layouts are
important, because again, we
have one release of Android
for tablets and phones.
So this is sort of a pattern
people have been using in
mobile apps since
the beginning.
You have, say, your
Contacts App.
You have this table of contents
that lists all of
your contacts, you click on
somebody, and it'll take you
into a Detail View.
So what we've done is we've
broken that up into what we
call fragments, so you can go
and lay them out side by side.
So now, same views, you still
have that table of
contents on the left.
You still have your details on
the right, but you can go and
stack them and rearrange them.
And so this does two things.
One, it's a really intuitive way
to go into the device as a
user, and as an app developer,
it allows you
to reuse your code.
It's actually the exact same
code laying out that table of
contents and displaying that
Detail View, we're just going
in and rendering both of
them simultaneously.
And there's a lot of options
are to go in and rearrange
things, too.
So you can go and of course,
place them side by side like I
did in that example, or you can
go and stack them on the
right, stack on the bottom, have
things slide in and out.
We've added commands to
go and do animation.
So there's lot of different ways
to go and compose your UI
and make something that looks
really beautiful.
And as an app designer,
it's up to you to
figure out what works.
We've given you the tools to
make sure that you can do it.
I mentioned gestures already.
Gestures are really important.
We want to make sure that your
device feels like an actual
environment that users
are interacting with.
So we've actually documented a
whole set of common gestures,
things that app developers will
want to go and integrate
into their app, things like
double tapping to go and zoom
in, being able to go and swipe
left and right to go and move
between pages.
Actually, that's what my
next slide will talk a
little bit more, too.
Drag and drop, we've added a
lot more APIs to go and let
you go and take care of drag and
drop and move data between
different fragments.
Swipe Views.
Like I said, you want to make
sure you can go and page
through the different
parts of your app.
We've added a class to our API
called View Pager that makes
this really easy.
And one last thing to talk about
here is, make sure your
app feels like a pure
Android App.
So I've taken a collection
here of UI elements from
different mobile OS's.
And functionally, they're
all the same.
A button is a button, a check
box is a check box, a text
field is a text field.
But visually, they look
completely different.
And if you're porting your app
over from one environment to
another and you use the visual
elements from that other
environment, not only is it
going to make your app just
look wrong, it's going to
confuse users too, because on
other environments, they
actually do have subtle
differences in behavior.
And this is not just about
making sure your buttons look
the same, but the way things
behave and the way
things are laid out.
So to give you a few examples
here, we have the Dialer App.
And when you're in the Dialer
App on the Android, you'll
notice that there is, again,
that Action Bar at the top
that contains your navigation.
On the right here, we have the
Dialer App from IOS, and that
Tab Bar is at the bottom.
And you never have a Tab Bar
at the bottom on an Android
app, but yet, we see
app developers go
and make that mistake.
To give you a couple other
examples here, Back Commands
that are actually labeled you'll
never do, it's always
that Up Command.
And when you're in a List View,
you should never have
right-facing chevrons.
When you're in a List View,
it should be obvious
you're in a List View.
Remember that screen shot I
showed of Android 1.5 where we
had all those really
confusing chevrons.
Of course, those pointed down
and I have no clue where down
goes, but is that really any
different than right?
When you click on something in
Android, it doesn't side of
the way, it just jumps into
that next screen.
So a right-facing chevron
doesn't make any more sense.
So we've taken all of these tips
and even more, and we've
put them on a site that we call
Android Design, and we
just launched it a
few weeks ago.
And we've put together a lot
of resources for you as app
designers, weather it's UI
essentials for Photoshop, all
of the design philosophy and
design patterns that I've
mentioned, put them up there for
you as well, basically so
that you can figure out
everything that we were
thinking when we were developing
the OS, that you
can apply those to your app.
So if there's one thing that
you take out of this talk
today, it's this URL here,
developer.android.com/design.
Go there, read through it all,
internalize it, and do what we
did with Honeycomb and
Ice Cream Sandwich.
Take a step back.
Ask yourself, is there some
assumption I've been making as
an app developer as to how users
are using my app, and is
there some way I can simplify it
and make it feel more like
an Android app, make it feel
more at home, and in doing so,
make it a bit more beautiful?
All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank
you, Trevor.
So while Trevor's taking down
his laptop and we're getting
Jonathan Beri set up here, we do
have a moment or two for a
few questions.
Does anybody have questions
for Trevor
about the Android universe?
Yes.
MALE SPEAKER: Are you
taking questions
not related to design?
TREVOR JOHNS: Sure.
Maybe, yeah.
Depends on your question.
MALE SPEAKER: So is there a way
right now, there's these
apps called Mr. Phone, for
example, that intercept the
incoming call to check if the
phone number is from a
spammer, and that functionality
doesn't work on
my Sprint Android phone, mainly
because Sprint is by
far the worst of the telecom
services, maybe.
But is that an Android feature
or a Sprint feature to turn
off that ability?
TREVOR JOHNS: So we have what
we call the Android
Compatibility Definition
Document and Compatibility
Test Suite.
And this is the set of standards
that tell device
manufacturers what an Android
device should behave like.
So this covers things
like API calls.
So if there's some API call
that's supposed to tell you
what number is calling and
that's not working, that means
that most likely, the device
manufacturer made a change to
the phone that for some
reason was not
covered by our test suite.
And I can tell you right now
that API call should be
mentioned in our CDD, our
compatibility definition.
So I'd want to actually take
a look at that app and see
exactly what it's doing
and why our test
didn't catch that.
So if you talk to me after the
talk, I can take a look at it
and try and get some more
information and figure out
what exactly is going
on there.
Android devices should always
behave the same no matter who
manufactured them.
Even if they've gone and
modified the UI, the API calls
should always be identical.
All right any other questions?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: No more
Android questions?
All right, thank you
so much, Trevor.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I also want
to say to the Live Stream
viewers out there, if you have
questions, please feel free to
+Mention me on Google+, ask
your questions during the
talk, and I'll make sure that
we get them answered on the
live stream.
I'm Timothy Jordan, by the way,
and you can find me, of
course, on Google+.
And next up, we have Johnathan
Beri, who's going to be
talking about Hangout Apps, and
really the next generation
of social applications.
JOHNATHAN BERI: Wait for
the screen to load.
How's everybody doing today?
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
JOHNATHAN BERI: It's a
little drier, right?
We planned that on purpose.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Do we have any
more Android questions while
we're working this out?
Come on.
Who here has an Android
device?
You are my people.
Who here doesn't have
an Android device?
You invert probably,
most likely?
Except for the guy who is
actually texting on a
non-Android device.
Hi.
No, no worries.
And have you all tried
out the new ICS?
Have you run Ice
Cream Sandwich?
No?
Where do you try it?
Trevor, where do they try it?
TREVOR JOHNS: Next door,
at the Android House.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: There you go.
Are we ready?
JOHNATHAN BERI: All right,
we're good to go.
So now, we're going to talk
about Hangout Apps, Hangout
Apps being the next generation
of social apps.
My name is Johnathan Beri.
I'm a Developer Advocate working
on Google+ and Google
+ Hangout Apps.
I'll be joined shortly
by some of my
colleagues, Julia and Wolff.
But before I begin,
I want to talk a
little bit about Hangouts.
So in the audience, not
the live stream,
who's been in a Hangout?
Awesome.
Who's had a Hangout
with their family?
Strangers?
Bosses?
All right.
Drinking?
No, OK.
Sorry.
Hangouts are a new medium
of communication.
They're bringing people
together in ways that
telecommunication hasn't done
in the past. It's a rich,
immersive experience,
multi-user, 10 people at a
time, conversing, coming,
going, meeting,
shaking hands virtually.
And it's actually a
transformative medium.
It's making things happen that
was not possible before.
I'll give you an example.
Daria Musk was a small-time
performer in the forest of
Connecticut doing some random
gigs in New York
whenever she could.
She first heard about Google+
and got on, saw a stream, and
started meeting people, and
then she saw Hangouts.
And as a performer,
she thought,
what if I did a concert?
I know there's not a lot of
people on here yet, it's new,
but let's just see
what happens.
I'll open it up to public
and start singing.
Within the first hour, she
actually overloaded our
systems and we had to go
behind the scenes and
reconfigure, because there's
such an interest in listening
to Daria Musk perform.
She went on for six hours.
And from this small town girl
performing in New York's bars
to a global success.
Not only was she able to sing
and engage with the audience,
she could talk directly to the
people in the Hangout.
It's a way you can connect that
you could never really
connect before on
a global stage.
So it turns out, Hangouts
are really good at
bringing people together.
And when people come together,
they want to laugh, they want
to joke, they want to cry, but
they also want to do stuff
together, they want to
collaborate, they want to
build, they want to think.
And that's where Hangout
Apps come in.
Hangout Apps allow third party
developers to create
applications that are inside
the Hangout experience that
extend the conversation.
Now, what makes Hangout Apps
unique, just besides being
inside of this video system, is
the fact that they can be
real time, they're
people-centric, and they have
access to rich media that you
can integrate within your
application.
Let me actually stop talking
about Hangout Apps and show up
Hangout Apps.
So I'm in a standard Hangout,
and Wolff is the big screen.
Say hi, Wolff.
And Julia, who's actually
in the back.
JULIA: Hi.
JOHNATHAN BERI: Wolff, I
think you're on Mute.
So let me load up an app.
So what you see here is
a Hangout App running.
Above the film strip and below
the Menu Bar is the real
estate for a Hangout App.
Essentially, it's an i-frame.
You can do whatever
you want with it.
Of course, we have APIs that you
can integrate, which I'll
show in a second.
Now here's the idea we had.
We're having a lot of fun at
South by Southwest. We're
working hard.
And we decided, what can we do
to stay longer at South By?
So the film event
is coming up.
Let's submit a film into that.
We're going to actually use the
Hangouts and Hangout Apps
to collaboratively build a film
together so we can get it
done in record time so we
can actually party more.
I mean, work more.
So this is actually a Google
Earth plug-in.
If you haven't seen it, it's
a really cool plug-in, it's
using our 3D map data, I can
zoom around the world.
But for this movie, we
need to first start
with filming locations.
So guys, do you have any ideas
of where we should film?
JULIA: Well, let's see.
Coming from San Francisco, I
say, let's check that out.
WOLFF: I think we want to make
a documentary about bears, so
I'm going to look for
Yellowstone Park.
JOHNATHAN BERI: Well since I'm
in Austin, I think I'm going
to go there.
So as you can see, Julia has
already put some pins on, I
just put a pin on.
And what we're demonstrating
is the social
piece to Hangout Apps.
This is a shared experience,
and our applications take
advantage of that and
build that in too.
You'll also see that I can
see what [INAUDIBLE]
they're doing.
That's because we have
an API that makes
real-time apps possible.
We call that the share state.
The share state is pretty
flexible, too.
It's not just putting pains
into Google Earth.
We can do a lot more with it.
To demonstrate, I'm
going to actually
start following Julia.
And what I'm doing is moving in
sync with what she's seeing
on her laptop over there.
So when she pans around, it
moves my globe around.
And it's not a screen share,
this is the actual application
updating in response to
what she's doing.
So to explain a little bit
further, I'm going to explain
how the API works.
Let me get out of Full Screen.
Finally.
All right.
So this is a representation of
the three different apps we
have running on our respective
machines, here's Julia, Wolff,
and I. In the bottom
there's a box.
This represents the
shared state.
It's kind of like a data store,
and it's where we store
the information that
we pass around.
So there's application code that
calls the API on Julia's
machine that says, hey,
I'm at the US.
This is the lat and
long positions.
And the API passes that
to our shared state,
and it's stored there.
Simple JavaScript call to send
that over, you don't have to
do crazy posts or deal with
cross-browser issues.
The API handles that for you.
Now almost instantly, the back
end sends that information to
all the app instances.
So we have three here, if we had
10, all 10 people inside
the Hangout would have that
same information.
Again, because it's our API, you
don't have to build this
real time back end, a pub-sub
system, dealing with set up
back end servers for
this piece, it
just happens naturally.
Also, you'll notice that it
goes to Julia as well.
It actually goes to everybody,
so you don't have to deal with
figuring out who sent what
message, it just gets
propagated.
Now we just have a bit of
application code that says,
hey Google Earth, go to that
new location, and we're
synchronized.
It's that simple.
It's about five lines of code,
10 lines of code, all in
JavaScript.
So now back to our
movie, because we
really want to stay.
I'm going to load up the second
app that we put in.
So guys, I don't think we have
a good handle on where we're
going to shoot.
What can we do next?
JULIA: We can maybe look for
some costumes to use during
this movie?
JOHNATHAN BERI: Awesome.
So we're in this Costume App,
and it's going to help us try
on different things.
So the first thing you'll notice
is I can pick any one
of these guys and move
my head around.
This is kind of silly, but what
it's doing is using our
media APIs.
So we have an overlay API that
you can attach objects to and
track head movements.
I think Wolff is demonstrating
that it pans with you.
You can also resize, like Julia
has a jumbo mustache.
And you could also reposition.
Now, these are not
canned images.
These are actually ones that
we've drawn and uploaded to
the system and overlaid
to the API.
So you can do whatever your
creativity lets you do.
So to prove that, we can
even draw an overlay.
So forgive my artistic skills on
a track pad, but I'm going
to draw a crown, or a Bart
Simpson hat, however you want
to interpret it, and I'm
going to wear it.
And we're just taking advantage
of some of the HTML5
features that will be
talked about later
today, and it's powerful.
And this is fun, this is a toy,
but this actually has
real world applications.
For example, if you're building
a Hangout App that's
a game, the high score might
have a number that floats up,
or a crown if they just
beat the level.
But if you're doing a
productivity app and you want
to identify who's the current
color on the project plan, you
can identify that with a little
ID at the bottom.
So I hate to be the bearer of
bad news with all this fun,
but I don't think we have budget
or time to fly or build
all these costumes.
Is there any way we can stay
at South by Southwest?
Wolff, we can't hear you.
What was that?
JULIA: I think maybe we can
do an animated movie.
What do you think, Jonathan?
JOHNATHAN BERI: Ah, yeah.
I'm pretty sure we built in
animated features, too.
JULIA: Oh, that's great.
That's a great idea.
OK.
JOHNATHAN BERI: There we are.
Since I've been drinking a lot
of cheap beer, I don't know
about you guys, but PBR has
been rolling deep for me.
So I'm going to grab this PBR.
Oh, wait a second.
Ah, I got it.
That's my animated character.
I'm a hipster.
JULIA: Aw, man.
But you've totally already
sold out as a hipster.
I mean, I got to do that before
they sold out, with my
blue pigtails and all.
JOHNATHAN BERI: Awesome.
And Wolff is miming, but I think
he wanted to be a bear
from the beginning with
the bear documentary.
So if you notice, the mouths
are moving, and that's
actually using our
audio-video APIs.
So our animated character
is responding to the
volume of my voice.
There's a simple callback API
that triggers an event that
animates that mouth.
And Wolff, say something as
if you're a mime again.
And he's growling.
Growl.
All right, cool.
I think we're going to have to
do this animated film, we just
don't have the time for it.
Now, this has been a mix of
useful with productivity, as
in using Google Earth, as
well as playfulness.
We can go in either direction.
You can build a full-fledged
game.
So as part of the film, we
built this little game to
represent combining all
this stuff together.
So let's go to the--
I love this app.
So here's the premise.
We've been working really hard
on these demos, we were coding
late at the Googleplex, and
we lost track of time.
The doors are locked.
We can't get out.
And we really need to get to
South by Southwest so I can
give this talk.
So we're going to try to figure
out a way how we can
get out of the Google
headquarters and get to Austin.
The whole purpose is to
get into one of our
self-driving cars.
So I think I'll be the hipster,
going with the theme.
And here I am.
JULIA: You know, I really
dig these blue pigtails.
I'm going to go for
the girl here.
JOHNATHAN BERI: Awesome.
JULIA: And we know Wolff's
love of bears.
Oh, yep, there he is.
JOHNATHAN BERI: So first thing
I'm demonstrating here is that
same shared state that we used
to synchronize the globe,
we're actually synchronizing
our positions.
So if you were sitting by Julia,
you'd probably see me
walking around, and she's
actually moving her character
around her virtual world.
So to demonstrate that, we
have a little debugger.
Why don't you guys
move around?
So this information is
what's being stored
in the shared state.
It's just [INAUDIBLE]
with positions
and some other metadata.
And we've also carried over the
audio API effect, so our
mouths are still animated.
And that, we have a little
debugger for that, too.
This represents the volume of
my mic and the others' mics,
and that's what our animate
character is responding to.
Again, that's just a simple
hook into the API.
Now hey guys, do you have
any ideas how we
can get out of here?
JULIA: Well, I've heard that
we can map our way out of
here, but we kind of need to
know where we are, right?
JOHNATHAN BERI: Oh, let me go
over to the kiosk, do a little
Google search.
Boom.
Whoa.
Sensitive.
I think we're in Mountain
View, so let me look for
Mountain View.
JULIA: That sounds like
a good start.
JOHNATHAN BERI: I'm
feeling lucky.
All right, so let me double
click and zoom in, and--
whoa!
Wolff, where did you go?
Boom.
All right, I guess we
found one way out.
JULIA: Wolff has really
good aim.
JOHNATHAN BERI: How are
you in the Hangout,
but also in the car?
I don't know, we'll figure
it out later.
JULIA: You know Johnathan, I'm
really thirsty after that.
That was really stressful.
So I'm going to get a soda.
JOHNATHAN BERI: Sure.
I'll grab a Mentos
or something.
JULIA: Yeah.
Let's just take a break and
figure out the next steps.
JOHNATHAN BERI: Hey,
wait a second.
Mentos?
Diet Coke?
Do you know what I'm thinking?
JULIA: I think I'm thinking
what you're thinking.
I think I need to strap this
absurdly large bottle of Diet
Coke to my back like a rocket.
Oh yeah.
JOHNATHAN BERI: Betcha
there'll be a
lot of fuel in that.
OK, so if I just splash
in some Mentos--
JULIA: Yep.
JOHNATHAN BERI: Boom!
Wait, are you there?
Did get in the car?
JULIA: Whoa.
JOHNATHAN BERI: And
that was fun.
All right, so I'm the
last man standing.
Um, I need to get out.
How do I get out of here?
There's got to be, I don't know,
like a door or something
that we don't know about?
JULIA: I think that a door
probably should've been our
first guess, but I think
you should try it out.
JOHNATHAN BERI: Oh yeah,
that's right.
I'll use the search.
Let's see, door.
I think we have one of those.
Oh, that's great.
Open sesame.
Did it work?
I feel like I'm in the
Twilight Zone.
Ah, there we go.
No we're off to Austin.
Dum, dum, dum.
Well that was fun, right?
It was playful, and that shows
some of lighter sides of
Hangout Apps.
But the Hangout Apps can kind go
across the entire spectrum.
Since it's really an i-frame for
you to work and integrate
with into, as developers, you
can do everything from
productivity apps, to music
collaboration apps, to
research and discovery.
But of course, games too.
The Hangout Apps, because
they're social, because
they're real time, and because
they have access to this media
that brings people together,
it's a new generation of
social apps.
This is also a new frontier.
We're in Developer Preview,
and we're working our way
towards out of that.
So that you can be first on
board to bring your apps
inside of Hangouts.
And I think that's it.
One second, sorry.
My final slide.
I go into any code today, so
we have a code lab in the
afternoon that you'll
actually build.
Sit down, in three hours by the
end, you should have our
canned app and anything that
you can come up with.
We'll go through the nitty
gritty of code, answer
questions, go through demos.
And you'll become Hangout
App ninjas.
And then finally, our developer
site has the
documentation that you need to
research if you're on the live
stream, and that's
developers.google.com/+, as in
the plus symbol, hangouts.
And those are our Google+
profile links, so
you can circle us.
Some more questions?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great.
Thank you, Johnathan.
JOHNATHAN BERI: You're
welcome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And we're going
to actually have YouTube
come up and start plugging in
their laptops while you bring
down yours and we answer
a few questions.
And we have a question from the
internet first. A lot of
people out there on
the internet.
And they would like to know,
Jonathan, if they'll be able
to change the whole layout
of the Hangout
Window with the API.
JOHNATHAN BERI: Currently,
we don't allow ability to
customize the layout.
We just have APIs that detect
things about the layout.
So for example, if the chat pane
is open, you have an API
to know about that.
Whether a user's using the app,
so if they've switched
off the app and they're just in
the Hangout, you can detect
things like that.
That's a great feedback.
We've heard that from a few
people, and we're looking for
ways to sort of customize
the experience
a little bit further.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great.
Do we have any questions from
the audience, the live in
here, in person audience?
I can see you in front of me,
and I can start to pressure
you for questions
if you'd like.
Oh, question over here.
MALE SPEAKER: We use
Live Stream a lot
on the YouTube side.
So one of the benefits of using
Live Stream is being
able to put in pre-rolls
and mid-rolls.
Is it possible to do the same
on the Hangout Side?
JOHNATHAN BERI: So pre-rolls
and post-rolls.
There are some APIs around
muting somebody's video feed,
so you can black.
We also have APIs do avatars,
so static images.
I don't know if we had it in
this demo, but you can
actually even animate the
overlays, so you can display a
roll on top of the video feed,
it gets propagated over for
that particular person's feed,
and as part of the API, you
can integrate with that.
In terms of injecting right into
the feed, the APIs are
not there yet, but the overlays
are certainly
something you could do.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Cool.
We have time for maybe one
or two more questions if
anybody's curious about Hangout
applications or
Hangouts in general, or what
Johnathan's favorite
restaurant in Texas is.
No?
MALE SPEAKER: Which is?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What is your
favorite restaurant in Texas?
JOHNATHAN BERI: I've
only been to two.
IHOP and--
oh, three.
All right, the Moonshine one is
over around the corner, or
Moonshiners?
It's pretty good.
All right, thanks everybody.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, and I'm
sorry, I didn't introduce you.
Which, that's absurd of me.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: I'm
waiting for you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's
ridiculous.
You're going to be talking about
YouTube APIs and video
creation and curation, and some
pretty cool new stuff.
And you've got a lot of friends
with you, don't you?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes, I do
have a lot of friends.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Jarek Wilkiewicz.
I work for YouTube.
And we'll be talking about
mobile content
curation and creation.
Quick question.
Who in the audience develops
mobile apps or
has a mobile strategy?
And who doesn't?
OK.
If you don't, then maybe you
should go get a drink.
Otherwise, this might be quite
interesting for you.
So here's the agenda
for today.
We'll talk about the
opportunity, what's happening
in YouTube mobile, and then talk
about creation, curation.
So I'll talk about the APIs
that we have to enable
applications, then give you
examples of these applications
directly from our partners, and
then we'll talk a little
bit about consumption.
Now a warning.
We have nine demos, 20 minutes,
six companies will be
presenting, so this is going
to be a lightning talk,
lightning demo session.
Hopefully, we'll try to maximize
your time here.
So forgive me if we are going
super fast, but a lot of us
will be hanging out
later on today.
So you have any questions after
this, please feel free
to stop by.
Before we start, I would like to
give a shout out to people
on iStream, YouTube iStream,
since I know we quite a few
people watching as well.
All right.
So let's talk about
the opportunities.
Here's some stats that you
might find interesting.
We are having about four billion
views on YouTube
daily, out of which in 2010, we
had about 200 mobile views.
Last year, you can think about
how many we had if you have
any guesses, but actually,
the number was 600.
So the mobile traffic
has tripled.
Similarly for uploads, we're
getting 60 hours of video
uploaded to YouTube every
minute, out of which three
hours are coming from mobile
devices, and that number is
also growing very fast, which
brings us to creation.
We will actually have demos from
Avid, WeVideo, who are
here, and I'll show an
application from Vlix.
First, let's start
with the API.
So if you are building mobile
applications and you would
like to incorporate video
uploads to YouTube in your
app, you need to think
about authentication.
We prefer OAuth2.
It's your friend.
Client Login works, but it's
bad, it has a lot of issues.
Connections will probably drop
while you're uploading.
We do support resumable uploads,
so for those of you
that have used it, that should
be pretty straightforward.
If you haven't used it, it'll
allow you to pick up
where you left off.
Metadata is important, so make
sure that your uploads
actually have the metadata
associated with it because
that helps us with video
discovery and recommendation.
You need a developer key from
YouTube because that'll help
you analyze your uploads and
get additional analytics on
the actual performance
of the application.
And there's a little secret I
would like to share with you
that is pretty frequently
overlooked.
If you need application-specific
metadata
included in your upload, you can
actually use our developer
tags feature to associate
metadata that is only visible
to your application.
So next, we'll have a demo
from WeVideo, one of our
application YouTube
API partners.
I would like to invite John to
come up here and give a quick
overview of the company,
as well as the demo.
All right, go for it, and
you have two minutes.
JOHN CANNING: Right,
two minutes.
That's a lightning round
[INAUDIBLE].
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Maybe three.
JOHN CANNING: Greetings,
everybody.
I'm John Canney with WeVideo.
WeVideo is an online
collaborative video editing
platform, and I am about to put
all those words together
in one sentence.
The reason is because that's
exactly what we do.
We are hosted in a browser, but
now also, running on our
mobile phones.
We're collaborative, so your
friends can work together,
share video from any part of
the world, just like we saw
earlier with the Google+
example.
We're doing it with
video editing.
And then, having the real time
One Touch export out to some
of your favorite services.
Ours happened to be YouTube.
So let me show you a demo.
That's a whole lot more
meaningful than
talking about it.
So the first thing is, I've
got my mobile phone.
Now the nice thing is, what I'm
going to do, I'm going to
go ahead and capture a picture
here of you fine people in the
crowd, lovely.
Thank you.
Thank you all for sitting
still on your laptops.
That's appreciated.
And then I'm going to
go ahead and upload
my media right there.
So what I'm doing is I'm now
uploading it into a project
that I created for everybody
to share at South by
Southwest. So that's
one side of it.
This is released now in the App
Store, able to get it on
your smartphones and start
contributing and collecting.
That's one side of it.
The next side of it
is let's edit it.
So this is going to
be coming soon.
It's the tablet form
of our editor.
And so what you now have is
all the stuff I've been
uploading, all the stuff my
friend Yostein has been
uploading, but in
an Editor Form.
So I can sit there, go ahead
and play with it.
We can notice the unfortunately,
we don't have
that exciting weather here, as
she was commenting earlier,
freezing out there,
the poor thing.
But this is the power
of the platform.
So you're shooting it on one
platform, editing it on
another, and sharing
it with friends.
And then when I'm done, going
ahead, one touch, pushing it
to YouTube.
So thank you very much,
we're WeVideo.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN CANNING: Thank you, Art.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Thank you, John.
Now we'll have a
demo from Avid.
Who in the audience has
heard about Avid?
You're doing video editing?
Yeah, a fair amount
of hands up.
And I'd like to introduce
[INAUDIBLE] from Avid, who is
going to tell us about
the company and
give us a quick demo.
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
about a month ago, and I'm
going to very, very
briefly show you--
I'm going to very briefly show
you how you can do big screen
editing on your [INAUDIBLE]
using the
Avid Studio for iPad.
There we go.
Avid Studio for iPad, it's very
intuitive, you just open
up a new project.
You don't even have to
name it right away if
you don't want to.
I'm going to pull some clips
from my video library down
into the storyboard.
I don't have to worry about the
order that I put them in,
because it's going to be easy
to rearrange [INAUDIBLE] in
the storyboard.
[INAUDIBLE].
I can also capture video and
pictures from within the app.
I'm going to put a still picture
from the airplane
yesterday down into the
storyboard, and I can add a
bit of Ken Burns effect on it
by doing a pan and zoom.
There we go.
We have some transitions here,
A to B. Also, I like the
little [INAUDIBLE] fade there,
so I'm going to put it in
between my picture and video
clips, just to create smooth
transitions.
I can also put some standard
title in here.
This is [INAUDIBLE].
I can move that around, maybe
there [INAUDIBLE].
--one that I really like, so I'm
going to put that at the
end of our storyboard.
Since we're talking about being
your own personal VJ,
I'm going to call it like
it is, Wahoo YouTube.
There we go.
I can also make that bigger.
And wouldn't it be nice if that
just was overlaid on top
of that last clip, that
last video clip?
I'm going to go ahead
and do that.
It wouldn't be complete
without music.
My iTunes library is right here,
so I can pull any track
onto the timeline.
You've got three channels there
for audio, so if you
wanted to do music and overdub,
and if you wanted to
put some Foley in there, however
you want to do it.
It's just as easy to edit
the music channels
as it is the video.
I'm going to make a clean
edit there, get rid of
the excess, and bang.
We have a video.
There we go.
It gets smoother
as you render.
We don't even have time for that
today but it is a very
fast render.
And once you're done with that,
you're going to put it
right onto YouTube.
Simple, simple [INAUDIBLE].
There we go.
And that is Avid Studio
for iPad.
[APPLAUSE]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: And if we
can switch back to the
projection screen?
OK, so demo in this
category, Vlix.
It's a mobile app for
smartphones that allows you to
do video anything and special
effects right
there on your device.
Vlix is an API partner
of YouTube.
They also have a web app
on YouTube.com/create.
And let's switch to the iPad
that I have here to give you a
quick demo.
So the way it works, you can
actually shoot a video right
from the device, as you would
expect so I'm just going to go
ahead and do it.
Here, hello, there's the bar.
How's it going?
All right.
And then I like the video,
so I'm just going to go
ahead and use it.
We can add a couple of effects,
so let me just
improve the contrast on it,
maybe I'll make it black and
white right here.
And then--
you can't see the demo?
It's coming back?
MALE SPEAKER: We have
you on here.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Did you
check your cables?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Maybe
cable problem?
Should we switch
to our backup?
OK.
So you guys can see that.
Once I apply the effect, I can
hit Next, and then share it to
my social network, my
YouTube account.
So it's pretty straightforward.
OK, let's switch back to the
presentation screen.
So we will now talk
about Curation.
Curation is very important to
us, and we have been adding a
lot of API support
to improve it.
So if you're building a curation
app, what's important
is search capability, again,
exposed via the APIs.
You can find out what content
is related to a given video
that your user is playing.
Watch_later, you can discover
what has been saved for
watching, you can discover
programmatically
what has been watched.
Trends and there's more APIs
coming, so if you're
interested in this category,
I'll be around later and
tomorrow, talk to me.
And now we're going to have a
couple of more demos, starting
with Squrl.
So let's try this [INAUDIBLE].
MARK: Hi.
So I'm Mark, this is Michael,
we're co-founders of Squrl.
At Squrl, trying to be the best
place to discover and
watch video on your
mobile device.
Right now, we're available for
the iPhone and the iPad.
We've been featured in the New
and Noteworthy Section of the
App Store and achieved the
rank of Number Six in
Entertainment Apps.
We have millions and millions
of videos in our system,
thousands of feeds, hundreds of
providers, YouTube by far
being the largest.
Having said all that, at the
end of the day, what we're
trying to do for our users is
get them to videos that they
care about.
So how do we do that?
At Squrl, the first thing that
you do when you come in to our
app is we allow you to
personalize your video
experience.
So you have the ability to
select from all the providers
that we have. These providers
match up to certain given
interest categories
inside of Squrl.
MALE SPEAKER: Can we switch
to the overhead?
MARK: So for example, we have
technology, and Michael can go
through and add in different
providers that map to those
interest categories, news--
Wall Street Journal, CBS
News, New York Times--
it's basically building a
personalized channel guide.
And when he's done with that,
he can get into our Fresh
section, give you a little
tutorial on how to use the
app, but you come into our Fresh
section, which is the
latest and greatest videos from
all the providers you
just selected put into a dynamic
playlist in that
interest category.
So you can simply, he'll select
from Comedy, you can
start watching video across all
those different providers
in a very nice, laid-back way.
Inside of Squrl, you can share
videos across your different
social networks, you can like a
video on Squrl, you can add
to your queue to watch later.
We also have a section
called What's Hot.
What's Hot is essentially
trending video that's trending
across all those different
providers that we're tracking
and all the different
social networks.
And finally, you're able to sign
in or authenticate with
your YouTube account, Netflix
account, Twitter, or Facebook.
And if you sign in with your
social networks, you're
actually able to share video
directly and message directly
with your friends as well as see
their activity inside of
Squrl and use them as a jump-off
point for video.
So thank you for having
us to YouTube.
We really enjoy working with
their team and their APIs.
[APPLAUSE]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: All right.
And I would like to invite
Hannah from LinkTV to talk
about LinkTV and give
us a demo as well.
Thanks, Hannah.
HANNAH EAVES: Thanks.
Hey, everyone.
I'm from LinkTV. LinkTV
is a national--
I guess we're going to switch
right to the demo.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Nope,
go ahead.
HANNAH EAVES: OK, all right.
LinkTV is a national satellite
TV station, about 33 million
US households.
We've won a Peabody Award for
curating and translating
Middle Eastern online and for
broadcast. And so basically
what we've done is we've done
a bunch of digital projects,
including a news website that
takes this kind of curation
and translation global and
brings them all onto a website
and into some mobile apps that
I'm going to demo here, that
are still kind of in the
prototyping stage.
So what we do basically is about
80% of the content we
curate is from YouTube and plays
through the YouTube API.
About 20% we produce
ourselves.
So we have environmental
programming, we cover Asia,
Asian bloggers, video
bloggers.
And then we perform natural
language processing on YouTube
videos to pull out automatically
peoples, places,
organizations.
We use Zymanta as a partner
for that piece.
And then we use that to do a
live search to create related
content on the fly.
So I'm going to switch
to the demo now.
If you want to sign up for this
app when it comes out in
summer, you can go to
linktvapps.com, and there's an
invite list there.
So here we have basically, kind
of your Home Screen, a
curated list you can see, from
all sorts of different
sources, Al Jazeera
English, ITN.
We've got our own programming
here through
Earth Focus, Link Asia.
We're also using these tags so
that you can see when we offer
the local perspective,
which is kind of one
of our unique offerings.
So here you see the Iranian
election form PressTV, so
that's the Iranian state
broadcaster that we're offering.
And then we have also, we're
looking at the best raw video
that you can see every
day based on what's
happening in the news.
So I'm just going to jump
into a video here.
So here's everyone knows about
the KONY video, this is like
the biggest thing right now.
But you can see here, we've
got related information.
You might not know
who Kony is.
So we do in an automated way.
So we're enhancing kind of
YouTube's metadata by creating
our own set of metadata.
So Kony, Uganda, International
Criminal Court, and then we
also kind of bring in related
content from other sources,
articles, tweets, social
media, and other videos
related to this video.
So this is kind of just
the beginning.
We also are building
out Map features.
And there we go.
There's kind of a preview of
kind of what the Map feature
is going to look like, and you
can check it out in summer.
Thanks.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Thank you.
Is that yours?
HANNAH EAVES:: Yeah.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
Thanks, Hannah.
Next up is business.me.
It's a very interesting
spin of curation.
OSCAR MORENO: Thank you.
OK, so we are business.me.
We are a personalized business
video network.
We focus on videos about
business topics, and we do
three things.
We do curation, we have an
editorial team that selects
the best business videos and
organizes the videos in
different sectors.
We do personalization.
We use LinkedIn to tailor make
your views, depending on your
professional interests and
depending on your professional
connections.
And we promote the contribution
of business
videos by allowing users and
companies to upload video or
share video.
So let's go to the demo, the
mobile web app is a prototype.
We have focused on the
consumption of video.
So you have several
views here.
The first one is the Editorial
Picks, which is our curation
effort where we select the best
videos from the web about
business topics.
Then you can go into your view
and you can sign in with
LinkedIn, and that way, we can
read your professional
interest. Also, what you
connections are watching in
business.me or are sharing, and
we can recommend videos
according to that information.
And you can also go to different
sectors and browse
and choose the sector you have
interest, for example,
development and design, and
choose a video here from
Google developers, and watch
video in the iPad.
So that's business.me.
It's a personalized
business channel.
And it's the best place to
share and discover videos
about business topics.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Great pitch.
Short and sweet.
Next up is ShortForm, and I have
to say that ShortForm has
inspired the title
of this talk, The
Video in Your Pocket.
Jeremy and Alex.
JEREME MONTEAU: Thanks, Jarek.
Hey, everybody.
I'm Jereme, a co-founder and
lead developer at ShortForm.
And this is Alex,
whose official
title is Tallest Engineer.
At ShortForm, we're all about
VJs, and turning viewers into
VJs, and helping them create
amazing channels.
VJs curate channels on ShortForm
just by watching
videos and clicking a button.
They can then share those
channels with their social
networks via email, and a
variety of different ways.
They can also embed their
channels on their website with
our embeddable widget.
Viewers can then watch channels
at ShortForm by
clicking on that the links
that they get.
The videos can come from
YouTube, Hulu, and a variety
of other sources.
They can watch on all screens,
including TV or on Google TV,
we're a spotlight app there, the
desktop obviously, and now
tablet and mobile, which we're
going to give you an early
preview of today.
The first step to bring
ShortForm to mobile is
providing a first class
viewing experience.
So now, when mobile users click
through ShortForm links,
they'll receive a mobile
optimized web application.
This is a channel about one of
my favorite subjects, my son.
So videos will play in their
embedded players in the page.
As users scroll down the page,
more videos will load, and
they can see the
whole channel.
So the next step to bringing
ShortForm to mobile is going
to be allowing curation directly
from the mobile app.
This is an early preview
as well.
People are going to be able to
click on Add, choose a channel
to put the video in,
and they're done.
They can then share those
channels with their audience
just by clicking on Share from
them mobile app as well, and
then viewers will get the
first class viewing
experience.
So I encourage all of you
to go become VJs today.
We're excited to announce that
we've opened up a weekly VJ
competition, so if your channel
is one of the top
performing channels on the
sites, you're eligible for
cash prizes.
So be heard, be a VJ.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: OK.
And then last but not least, I
wanted to chat a little bit
about video consumption and what
we're doing in this area
to enable applications.
So all the apps that you have
seen use our player, our
player API.
And on mobile specifically, we
have an iPhone player, which
allows you to actually embed the
video playback in a native
mobile application, so on
Android, in the web view, on
IOS, in UI web view.
The Object Embed is another
mechanism, it's a legacy
mechanism that still works,
specific to Safari, it's done
through Safari plug-in,
mobile Safari.
Obviously, you can launch the
YouTube application on the
mobile device if you wish.
Typically, it comes
pre-installed with the OS.
And then there's more coming.
We have a Code Lab at 3:00 PM,
so some of you in the audience
have signed up for
that Code Lab.
The Code Lab is full, but it'll
actually be dedicated to
improving the video playback
experience for mobile.
So I have two quick demos from
two companies that couldn't be
here today that really do very
interesting stuff when it
comes to optimizing the
playback experience.
ShowYou is one of them.
It was ranked Best
Social Networking
App in the App Store.
And then the next company
is NowBox, which is a
personalized guide that really
allows you to discover
interesting content on YouTube
and present your own
subscriptions in a way that
is very easy to consume.
So let's switch to the demo.
Starting with ShowYou.
So as you see, what ShowYou does
is presents videos on the
wall that actually can
be discovered by
simply browsing it.
So it's very interesting.
It's a different type
of user experience.
They also have social features,
they have featured
links, you can discover what
your friends have been
watching through connections
to social networks.
And then the NowBox user
interface is also quite
interesting.
If any one of you has a cable
box, this might look a
similar, because the programming
that you get from
Now Box resembles kind of
the familiar layout.
And based on your interest, they
actually build a complete
programming guide for you, so
you can just sit back, relax,
and watch the content that you
are already subscribed to, or
content that they have
recommended.
All right.
And now, we have run out of
time, but we've done it.
So thank you very much, that's
[INAUDIBLE] demos.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Great,
thank you.
And do we have one or two
questions about these YouTube
APIs, or even any questions for
any of the presenters that
have come up and demoed
with you?
Yes.
One second while I
run out to you.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What inspired
y'all to do all this, because
it's amazing.
I mean, wow.
Y'all should give yourselves a
round of applause as well.
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Well I mean,
thank you very much.
I think the credit goes to the
companies that presented.
I mean, we rarely provide the
tools, but they're the ones
that are innovating with it.
So I would like to give a
round of applause to our
presenters.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Any
other questions?
You got one more question.
Hold on, I'm going to
get by you here.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, cool.
I love all the content
curation.
I was wondering if they had a
quick second to talk about how
their curation and their apps
maybe integrates with
YouTube's already content
creation with like
subscriptions and
stuff like that?
JAREK WILKIEWICZ: Yes.
So you can integrate
subscriptions
programmatically.
So if you subscribe to a
channel in an app, that
subscription actually is
reflected in your YouTube
subscriptions.
As well as your actions, for
example liking a video, can
also be integrated,
so it actually
represents a like on YouTube.
So the API allows you that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: We actually
have time for one more
question if you have it.
No?
OK.
Well then, let's go
right into Cloud
Adventures, I like that title.
We have Iein and Michael here.
They're going to talk to you
about spending your time on
building your app, not
the infrastructure.
IEIN VALDEZ: Whoa.
Hello.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Iein Valdez with our Cloud
Developer Relations Team and
Michael, and we're here to talk
about cloud adventures.
Does anyone here build
apps today?
A few people build apps.
Does anyone use the
cloud for apps?
Couple people.
All right, well this is great.
So I'm going to tell you a
little bit about the cloud,
why you should care about it.
So the overview of the talk is
we're going to give a little
bit of history about web
application development, some
of the challenges like 10 years
ago, and where we are
today with App Engine and some
of our other products, talk a
little bit about some of the new
markets that are starting
to take advantage
of the cloud.
The web was sort of the primary
market, but now we're
seeing mobile, gaming, and
big data start to be real
industries that are taking
advantage of the cloud.
And then Michael's going to
talk about big query, big
data, and some of the things
we're doing there.
So this is a picture of my life
about 10 years ago, when
I was building web
applications.
I basically had this very
complicated process of putting
together this stack and figuring
out how to launch an
application.
It took really, really a lot
of time for me to manage
everything.
And then once I sort of figured
out the stack and I
actually started to write the
application and we had users,
we actually had to figure out
how to scale the application,
make sure the application was
running, and people could
actually get to our app.
I spent a lot of time managing
machines, figuring out how to
get a database working, backing
the database up,
running the database, load.
And then of course, the users,
which we were in the business
of making our users happy, we
actually did not spend a lot
of time on our users.
We spent most of our time
managing our stack, and that
was really sad.
And things are very
different today.
So just sort of recap some of
the problems when you're
building large scale web apps.
One is it's very difficult to
get up and running quickly,
and it's very difficult to
iterate on your application
and get it to the cloud.
It used take three months to
get a stack ready, up and
running, and pushing out builds
was like a weekly to
monthly process.
Today, you can do that
very quickly.
The infrastructure costs
were very painful.
So managing the hardware,
data centers, bandwidth,
multi-homing to make sure that
we were available if we one of
our data centers caught
on fire, very painful.
Back-ups, security upgrades, all
of this stuff we had to do
to just to make sure our
app was running.
And then databases were
super expensive.
So there's kind of two parts
to app developers.
There's one serving the request,
the other part is
actually persisting the data,
making changes on your mutable
data, and that was actually
really difficult.
So these were lots and lots of
different problems, and this
was sort of why App Engine
was created to
simplify this process.
And App Engine's philosophy is
to make it easy to build
applications number one,
easy to get started.
Easy to run and manage these
applications, so once you've
got it built and pushed, you
want to make it really easy to
kind of control it.
And easy to scale, and this was
really the key thing was
that all of that work on
infrastructure was just to
solve the scale problem,
and so we
packaged all that together.
And the other philosophy we
have is it's free to get
started and you pay
for what you use.
So it's really easy to get your
app up and running, and
it's not just for web serving
but also for data persistence.
So today, App Engine runs on
three languages, we have
Python, Java, and Go,
so it's pretty easy
to get up and running.
And I'm going to give you a
quick demo to actually show
you what it's like, how fast
you can get an app
running in the cloud.
So I'm on Mac OS and I have
the App Engine launched.
You can go to
appengine.google.com, download
this in a few minutes.
It runs on Mac OS,
Linux, Windows.
And I'm using the
Python version.
We're just going to create
a quick app here.
We're going to call
this Iein Demo.
And the nice thing about this
is it gives you a little
starter project.
And this starter project
is basically your
typical Hello World.
There's a few files for
configuration, but the main
application here really
is this Hello World.
So let's just say, Hello SXSW.
And I'm able to then run my
application on my machine in a
disconnected state and
test and build it.
So here's my application.
Pretty easy, it's running
locally on my machine, I can
make changes and iterate.
But now, let's see what it takes
to get this application
into the cloud up and running.
So we go back to our App Engine
Launcher, and we can
click Deploy.
And what this is basically
going to do is take my
application, package up the
files, and push it up to
Google's cloud.
So I've got my dashboard here,
and let's take a look here.
IeinDemoAppSpot.com, and there's
my application up and
running in the cloud.
So in literally a matter of
seconds, you can take your
application, your code on your
laptop, package it and have it
running in the cloud, and have
millions of users hitting your
application.
So that is super, super easy.
So that's a quick demo.
Let's talk about some of the
core features of App Engine.
So in terms of serving web
requests, we have sort of a
few core features.
We have front ends for short
bursty requests, we have back
end for long, long-limbed
requests, or maybe you want to
run code in the background
a lot.
Task Queues, to be able to queue
up work, and we Cron for
scheduling.
So there's some nice
features built in.
From the storage layer, we
have a couple different
technologies.
We have our Data Store, which
is really our key values
store, basically in the
cloud, very scalable.
We have CloudSQL, which is a
MySQL in the cloud, as well as
a high performance Memcache
layer to really aid
performance.
Services we have a number of
really powerful services.
We have Users API, Mail API,
Image, URL Fetch, MapReduce, a
really cool one called
TrafficSplitting, which
actually lets you deploy
multiple versions of your
applications and do AB testing
really simply.
So the key thing here is that
all of these services, from
the compute, storage, and users,
mail, et cetera, these
are all managed for you.
These are building blocks that
just run as a service.
You don't have to configure and
install software to make
these things work.
So let's talk a little bit about
where we are today in
the market.
So App Engine today serves over
five billion daily hits.
We have over a million
applications running on the
platform, and 150,000 active
developers building.
And you can see when we started
out in 2008, the
trajectory of this has just
been sort of going up over
time as we've added features.
So it's a platform that you can
launch your application
and know that it's going to
be there and running.
So I wanted to give a quick
example of what it was like to
quickly launch and host and
run an app in the cloud.
So hopefully everyone here
uses Google, and you know
there's the turkey
doodle, right?
And so this was actually an idea
of one of the engineers,
he wanted to build this turkey
doodle and launch it very
quickly, and he didn't really
know what tools to use.
So he decided to try out App
Engine and Go, and put this
turkey doodle together.
And so he was able in 24 hours
to basically create this
doodle, test it, and launch
it on the Google homepage.
So this is kind of a
cool little doodle.
It's an interactive doodle, you
can kind of click here and
customize your turkey, and
there's a sort of a slot
machine effect here so you
can get a random turkey.
Doodle and then you can, of
course, link and share with
your friends.
So the point was, this engineer
was able to use the
tools that are available to you,
build this doodle, and
launch it to millions of users
in a day, and you have that
same technology at your
disposal, which is very cool.
So quickly, a couple
of other--
and just as we talked about,
web was really a primary
driver, a great use case,
but now we have
cloud-enabled mobile.
So we have a massive number of
mobile devices coming online.
Everyone has a smartphone in
their pocket, they're becoming
internet-enabled, they're
generating
lots and lots of traffic.
Apps now share state, they're
no longer self-contained.
So they're making API
calls to back ends
and third party apps.
They're social graph
enabled, right?
You're pulling your friend
network in and so forth.
And of course now, there's video
upload and download.
So there's lots of information
being generated, you need to
serve this traffic.
How do you actually do that if
you're a mobile developer and
you don't know anything about
serving infrastructure?
So that's where you can use
something like App Engine.
I wanted to give a quick story
about a great case for this,
which is Outfit 7, they build
the Talking Tomcat apps, and a
bunch of apps you're probably
familiar with.
It's interesting because they
have, I think, over 14
applications launched.
They now have over 350 million
downloads of their apps.
Every day, over a million new
users on mobile devices are
installing this application.
And they're available in 120
different countries.
So that is a massive
amount of scale.
How do you actually
make your app run?
And they use App Engine
as part of their
infrastructure back end.
Another great use case
is Pulse Mobile.
So this is another example of a
mobile back end for Android,
IOS, Kindle.
Pulse is a news reading
application.
They use the Python runtime,
they're serving thousands of
queries per second, 100 million
daily requests coming
out of the platform, and it's
very cost effective for them.
So another example of a great
mobile use case to power your
application.
Another really interesting
market that's starting to take
advantage of cloud as
well is gaming.
So I was just at the GCC
conference, Game Developers'
Conference, and it was really
fascinating to see all the
developers out there, and cloud
was a really big topic.
So there's this really
interesting shift of a new
distribution model.
Sort of the old world was the
day when you had game
cartridges or DVDS or CDs, and
that's how you actually played
games, you put these things in
your gaming console on your
desktop and you ran it.
And we're now transitioning to a
new world of gaming, I think
partly to the desktop, which
is kind of fascinating.
So Chrome has this thing called
Native Client where you
can actually take your C, C++,
or any native code, run it
through the Chrome Sandbox,
and actually deliver those
games into the browser.
Very, very fascinating.
There's also HTML5 native games,
so you can run pretty
powerful games in the
browser alone.
And then there's sort of all in
the cloud, meaning gaming
is fully running in the cloud.
A great company that's actually
doing this OnLive,
and they're essentially running
the entire game on a
server somewhere else, and
they're just shipping the bits
over the wires, so you can just
play from any console.
It's very, very, very cool.
So how can App Engine help
you with gaming?
Well, there's a couple
of things.
All of these games of lots and
lots of static assets, so big
files that need to be served.
Data store for managing your
scores, games, leader boards,
and so forth.
So you need to be able
to have a scalable
database to handle that.
As well as for HTML5 games,
being able to serve up your
web apps, HTML, JavaScript,
and so forth.
So just a couple quick examples
of gamers that are
taking advantage of this.
Rovio built Angry Birds in
collaboration with us, and
it's a fully native web game,
HTML5, it's using play and
frame, our Google Web Toolkit,
Google+ integration, and App
Engine actually serve and run
all of this in the cloud.
So it's a great game,
check it out.
Chrome.angrybirds.com.
Another really good game in
the Chrome Web Store is
FieldRunners, that's another
example of a game.
So just to sum up, and I'm
going to hand it off to
Michael here in a second.
Think of using App Engine as,
it's a platform that's going
to allow you to be nimble focus
on your application.
It's perfect for web apps,
games, and mobiles.
So a great use case is, if
you're building any of these
things, really take a look at
the cloud and App Engine.
Focus on your application and
not the infrastructure.
Don't worry about managing.
You're not going to be an
expert, just let us do the
heavy lifting for you.
And so running the app is
easy, but how do you
fine tune it, right?
There's all this data
being generated.
Are your users happy?
How can you take advantage
of this?
How can you help make your
application better?
And I think that's where all of
this massive amount of data
that's being generated, you need
to sort of figure out how
you can derive insight from
this before it's too late.
And that's where sort of these
big data technologies are
really starting to come into
play, and Michael's going to
talk about big data.
So thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL: Hey, everyone.
Can you guys all hear me?
Yeah?
So yeah, thanks for
being here.
My name is Michael, I
work with Iein on
the Cloud Devel Team.
OK, So if you've read a tech
blog in the last three months,
you've heard the term "big
data." it's a buzzword.
It means two things when
it's a buzzword.
One, nobody knows what
it is, and two,
there's a lot of hype.
But I think there's a lot of
validity in using big data
analytics for all kinds of
applications, and I'm very
passionate about this.
The other cool thing about this
sort of like hype around
big data is that there's a lot
of cool tools coming out,
things that we couldn't even
have imagined two years ago.
And I'm going to talk
about one of them
today, Google Big Query.
But if you're interested in
doing something with data
analytics, I'm going to
tell you a story.
You probably know the story if
you've already done this, and
if you're thinking about getting
into it, you're going
to learn this story.
So let's start with
a single record.
Here's a single record.
It's easy to work with,
it fits on your local
workstation, you can develop
with it without having to
worry about extra hardware
or extra infrastructure.
And your manager, and in fact,
this happened to me last week.
My manager came up to me and
said, we need to build a data
visualization app based on some
of the data you have. And
I said great, simple.
No problem, right?
You just build it.
You can use the same kind of web
stack you're normally used
to, same tools on your
workstation, you're fine.
Well, it's a hit.
Now you're a mobile gamer, and
you decide, well, I want to
build a crowd-sourced app that
shows you which buildings are
best suited for defending
against zombie attacks or
something, right?
So you're using crowd-sourced
data, a lot of data, now you
have a million records.
No, wait.
Now you really have a million
records, right?
You have a lot of data.
Now, this is still OK.
You could probably handle this
on the normal application
stack that you have, some of
the software that you're
using, you're used to.
But there's going to be a point
where those tools may
not work, and that's when you
get something like a billion,
and now you've got a
big data problem.
So what are some of the things
that you might have to do when
you get to billions of records,
gigabytes of gigabytes.
Well, maybe you shard your
traditional MySQL database.
Maybe you buy new software,
you're switching from one
stack to another, you're going
from a relational model to a
no SQL model.
Or maybe you're preprocessing
data for analytics.
So you're running your
traditional MySQL database
overnight to get some
kind of results.
And then maybe you need
more employee time or
you need more employees.
And that's when things
get a little crazy.
Then your database starts
looking like the Borg
spaceship and you've got
terabytes of data, and then
you're in real trouble, because
then maybe you have to
rethink your whole system.
So let me tell you about
scale, right?
So as you move from paradigm
to paradigm, what happens?
Well, you can maybe predict the
cost of new storage, or
instances, or virtual machines,
there may be a fixed
cost there.
But moving from gigabytes to
terabytes, moving from
paradigm to paradigm,
I don't know.
You don't know what it costs.
It's hard to predict.
And new expertise, new
employees, these are things
that are hard to predict.
So the total cost of
your scale-up,
you don't know, right?
And so when you don't know,
you're not in the application
business anymore.
You're in the infrastructure
business.
And you're an application
developer.
You're making a game, you're
making a crowd-sourced mobile
app, something like that.
So you don't want to be in the
infrastructure business.
Google's been down this
road too, right?
When we were called BackRub and
we were just a glimmer in
a Stanford graduate student's
eye, we had 26 million pages
in our index, right?
And then two years later,
we had a billion.
So our data just scaled
enormously and we had to come
up with new tools
to handle this.
And then it quadrupled in the
next couple years, and then we
added an Image index.
And then by, let's see, 2008,
it hit a trillion, right?
So we've been down this road.
And now it's 2012, I think
we're at a gazillion.
I don't know what the number
is, some huge number.
So that brings to
Google BigQuery.
OK, so what is Google
BigQuery?
Google BigQuery is our
tool for analyzing
massive data sets.
It uses a SQL-style language
that you may already be used
to, makes it easy to write
queries on this data.
But the best part about it, as
a developer the thing I love
is it's an API, it's
a service.
You make calls to it via API,
you can use the programming
language of your choice,
it's a RESTful API.
So we use this technology
internally.
We've written a few
papers about it.
Internally, we call it Dremel,
and you can read the paper,
the research paper we
published, if you're
interested.
Without getting too technical,
I know this is a lightning
talk, I don't have a lot of
time, but it's really great
information.
We basically store the data in
a colander format, and it
helps us retrieve these kind
of queries quickly.
And so I'll show you a demo
in just a second.
One thing I want to tell you is
the way you use it is that
you take your data in CSV format
and you send it to
Google's cloud.
Once in there, you can ingest it
into the BigQuery data set,
and then it allows you to
run queries via API.
So since this is an API, we're
able to actually build a
browser client.
So when you sign up for
BigQuery, you have access to a
web browser tool, and that's
actually built
on top of the API.
So it's kind of like a way for
us to dog food our own
technology, so I'll show
you an example.
So here's this BigQuery
window.
This is a tool that let's
you browse queries.
You can see, I've been playing
with us today, there's a lot
of queries.
I'm going to show you how
fast this thing is.
This is pretty remarkable.
We couldn't do a lot of the
things at Google without the
speed that this technology
allows us to run queries with.
The first thing I'm going to
show you is a data set of all
the revision history of
Wikipedia up until about 2010,
which is a lot of data.
So let's count the records in
this data set, and I'll give
you a sense of how fast
this tool is.
So right now I'm running--
two seconds.
In two seconds, we return
the result.
I don't know if you can see it,
make it a little bigger.
330 million records
in that data.
So in two seconds, we
retrieved a count.
Now, the fun thing to do with
this data set is to see what
were the most revised
articles, right?
Which articles got the
most attention?
So let's do this query,
this will tell us.
Let's run that and see
how long this takes.
The most revised.
Try to think about it before--
it's already done.
George W. Bush.
And I'm always fascinated by
this, followed by World
Wrestling Entertainment
employees pages.
I think I know why George W.
Bush might be revised a lot.
I wasn't sure about the
World Wrestling thing.
I think it's because there's a
lot of fanboys and they like
to add new stuff, the plot
lines are going on.
So I was looking at this data
set and I thought, you know, I
want to know why these
things are revised.
So I started looking at the
George W. Bush article, and I
realized that when people revert
due to vandalism, they
have a comment in the
revision history,
reverted due to vandalism.
So I wanted to see how many
articles were reverted due to
vandalism or contained vandalism
in the comments?
And what's fun about BigQuery is
it's so blazingly fast, you
can run these ad hoc queries
over and over.
So let's see if I can
find that one.
Sorry, I have to
zoom out a bit.
Oh yeah, here we go.
So let's see, vandalism in the
Revision History comments.
The answer may surprise you.
Ah, five seconds, right?
So we went through 100 million
rows in five seconds.
Yes, George Bush, a lot of
comments about vandalism, and
then Wikipedia itself, and
then Neopets, right?
And so I gave this talk at
another place and I said, you
know, I would probably
vandalize the Neopets
Wikipedia article.
And then Led Zeppelin, the
controversial band Led
Zeppelin, and then
Adolf Hitler.
So this is great, right?
This just shows you the power of
being able to query across
these massive data sets.
So I'm interested
in Wikipedia.
One of my coworkers at Google
gave me access to a Wikipedia
data dump of the actual text.
This is just the revision
history.
That's a very enormous set.
And I'm interested in bias, bias
language, because that's
something I'm interested
in studying.
So I tried to write
this web app.
Let's see if this
thing will work.
This is the Wikipedia
Weasel text finder.
So Weasel Words in Wikipedia
are words that have bias
language or bias
phrases, right?
So language like, "without a
doubt" or, "it should be
noted." So the Wikipedia editors
consider this language
to be indicative of bias.
So I wanted to see, what
articles contain
some of this language?
So I wrote this app that
actually scans the Wikipedia
text and in seconds, returns
articles that contain some of
this information.
So here's "many are of the
opinion." Now let's just pick
a random one like Menahem
the Essene.
Now if you go to this site, and
you can't really see it
well, but it looks like somebody
has already tagged
this as a Weasel Word, or maybe
this is an automated
process, I don't
actually know.
It's a Weasel Word.
So "many are of the opinion,"
bias language.
So I wanted to go back and see,
well, what about articles
with "it should be noted,"
or "without a doubt?"
Let's take a look.
And I'm scanning the
entire Wikipedia
corpus in seconds, right?
So here we go.
Here's a random sampling of
articles that contain this
bias language.
Here's one, "it should be
noted." So I don't know what
this airport is, but it should
be noted, and it's not marked
as Weasel Text.
So imagine what you could
do with this tool.
You could do a daily scan and
look for biased language in
seconds, right?
And you don't have to worry
about the kind of crunching
away, buying new servers,
et cetera, et cetera.
It's all in API, and
it's very fast.
So let's just recap this.
So I wanted to get two
points across to you.
One, your data analysis need
should scale with your data.
You shouldn't hop from paradigm
to paradigm to
paradigm if you know you're
going to scale up.
Your cost and technology
should be predictable.
That's the thing a lot of people
forget when they're
doing big data is they go from
software to software, and it's
great, and then they forget
about the cost of switching,
the cost of maintaining,
the cost of hardware.
And finally, don't build
infrastructure.
Build your app.
You're app developers, right?
So you can use this tool to
build cool mobile games,
crowd-sourced tools,
visualizations, dashboards.
We have people using it to
build game analytics
technology, we have people doing
things like with hotel
and hospitality industry, just
amazing amounts of data, and
being able to do real time
dashboards with this tool.
It's great.
So that's all I have for this.
I'm going to leave
this up here.
This presentation that I made is
actually in App Engine now,
and if you want to learn more,
AppEngine.google.com is where
you can go for App Engine, and
developers.google.com/bigquery,
and that's how you can
get ah old of us.
And I think we have just enough
time for questions.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yes, questions
about the cloud.
We do actually have
some time for a
fair number of questions.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm sorry
if I came in a
little late for this.
What's the pricing
model for the--
MICHAEL: Are you talking about
the BigQuery pricing model?
MALE SPEAKER: The BigQuery.
MICHAEL: So this actually,
we're still in limited
preview, and we haven't
launched an official
pricing model yet.
The one thing I can say is, the
cost of storing the data
is very similar to Google Cloud
Storage, it's a very
similar pricing model to that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: More questions
from the live audience?
No questions?
All right.
Oh wait, we got someone.
Last minute questions.
MALE SPEAKER: When do you expect
the big data stuff to
be launched?
MICHAEL: This particular
product is
very soon, very soon.
Like maybe a month,
a month or two.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, I know a lot
of times, the first time
you run a query it's slow, and
then later on, SQL cache
catches up and it
becomes faster.
Does that happen here, do
queries get faster the more
you run them, or
what kind of--?
MICHAEL: We don't have any
caching on the server.
You can do your own caching, and
that's a strategy a lot of
people use, but we
don't do any.
Anything else?
I will say one last thing.
If you're interested in using
BigQuery, you can sign up for
the limited preview and use it
before we do the general.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: More
questions.
Ooh, questions beget
MALE SPEAKER: So is this useful
both with structured
data and unstructured data?
MICHAEL: So this is for what we
call semi-structured data,
it's basically structured
data.
We support a limited amount
of data types.
MALE SPEAKER: What about
like [INAUDIBLE]
search and those things?
MICHAEL: That's maybe
an App Engine thing?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, we can do
that with App Engine, so you
can put your data into the data
source, SQL, [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Any more
last minute questions?
Going once, going twice,
going one to 100 times.
All right, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: --around
with HTML5 a lot.
Paul is here to talk to
you about just that.
PAUL IRISH: I think we have like
a bunch of seats up here
if you want to fill in.
Make sure it's not [INAUDIBLE]
crowded back there.
One, two, three, four.
Beautiful.
All right.
OK, I guess we'll get started.
My name is Paul.
I work on the Chrome Team doing
developer relations.
And so I like to talk a lot
about how to build web apps
and what are the new things
inside the browser that you
get to play with.
This talk in particular, we're
going to talk about the new,
new new, hot stuff, and some of
the cool features that you
have. So these sort of things
are available in Chrome
Canary, so Chrome Canary's a
daily build, you get an update
about once a day.
So it's all live, fresh new
stuff, not too many bugs, it's
pretty solid.
I like to run it side
by side with Sable.
But a lot of these are also in
other browsers too, like a
Firefox Nightly and
Upper Next.
So this is what we're going
to talk about today.
Firstly, we're going to stop
with some CSS, kind of what we
have as far as styling.
We'll get into some APIs that
are appropriate for games.
Then we're going to talk about
being a nice person to users,
and like saving their battery.
I'm plugged in, but my battery
dies all the time, so we're
talking about how to be very
conscientious about that,
which I think is a good thing.
And then I'm going to round up
with some real time voice and
video stuff that I'm really
quite excited about.
All right.
We're going to kick off, get
right into it, we're going to
talk about CSS Regions.
So CSS Regions is a really
powerful thing, and a lot of
this work actually
came from Adobe.
So here we have a layout with
just some Lorem Ipsum.
But you see we have a column
here, the text goes over to
here, and we have kind of this
area down here with a picture,
and then again
two columns down there.
So semi-complicated layout,
not too bad.
But we're using regions.
And so what that means is that
we've defined these regions.
I'm going to zoom out
once more up here.
OK, cool.
So I'm defining my boxes and
the geometry of my page.
And then I have my content,
which actually has all the
paragraph text.
So that means that the paragraph
text is just kind of
filling from box to box.
And so I'm going to add Content
Editable, I'm just
using the Chrome Dev tools and
adding Content Editable.
This allows me to
edit this text.
And so I could add in some
Chrome hearts HTML5,
something like that.
And maybe I'll just
paste it a bunch.
So you can see it's actually
pushing the text down into the
next column.
So this text is flowing from one
to the next to the next.
So I'm really excited about
this because it basically
allows for magazine
style layout.
Layout's always been a
challenge, but Regions gives
us a lot of power.
This right here is a prototype
browser build from Adobe, and
I'll show a few demos
from this one.
So this is similar to
the last one, I just
have these three boxes.
I'm going to resize it, and
you'll see the text is flowing
from one to the next to
the next, just kind of
filling up the space.
This is all just purely
defined in CSS.
In addition to Regions, the spec
also captures exclusions.
So this is, I want a circle
and a heart, and I want my
text to work around that, so
I've defined my shapes.
This is also completely dynamic,
so I could just
define this.
The text is just working its
way right around that.
This is the Debug View, kind
of what I see what the
actual shape is.
And then I've got two more
for you on this one.
Again, magazine style layout,
really gorgeous.
So we can just work against this
shape, even add in a bit
of just kind of tweaking that,
and I like this one a lot.
So here we have, let's
see, I'm going to
turn this off, yes?
OK, cool.
So what I have on the bottom is
actually the debugger you
turned on, so I do the shape
of my exclusion.
And so as I slide this, the
car enters, the mountain
shifts, and we're also seeing
all the text kind of just work
its way around it.
So this is a really
exciting stuff.
Adobe and WebKit are working
together on this, and it's
available now in
Chrome Canary.
You just have to go into About
Flags, where a lot
of this stuff is.
And inside About Flags, you'll
find a lot of interesting
experiments, and Regions is one
of the ones that we'll be
covering today, but a bunch
more stuff is in here.
All right, filters.
Now, SVG, if you've done SVG
work, they've had filters for
a long time, and we haven't
had them in CSS.
But you've probably wanted to
blur or something, or like
desaturate just a section
of the page.
Filters brings that,
and we have it now.
So I'll bring up this demo.
A nice little seascape,
let's see.
I'm not going to use
that picture.
We'll try that again.
That's pretty good.
So I have here, this is like an
image element, and I'll add
some contract.
So this is just the CSS line
that's making that change.
There's Drop Shadow in filters,
I can desaturate it,
or of course, we can blur it.
Now, I'm applying this just to
an image element here, but
this could be anything.
This could be a video element,
this could be a paragraph of
text, this could be--
you've seen in other cases where
like a modal pop-up will
come out, and then the entire
background will be like
semi-blurred, like I think
this is a common
technique in Flex.
You can do that, no problem.
And this works just like
any other CSS property.
So I can use a CSS Key Frame
animation, make your audience
sick, I'm sorry about that.
But there's a lot of power, and
this is baked right into
the platform.
Good, cool.
I want to give a shout out
to navigator.connection.
So this is an API where a lot
of times, you'll be building
like a mobile app and you want
to know, it would be really
handy if you knew exactly
what sort of connection
your user was on.
You're going to send out high
resolution imagery if you know
they're on a fast connection.
Otherwise, you're going to tone
it down a notch, maybe
not even send any images at all,
maybe just small sizes.
So Navigator.connection type has
been available on Android
for a while, it's not
in IOS as of yet.
They're still actually working
out maybe a potential
improvement to the spec, but
this allows you to have that
sort of control and act
upon the network
layer inside the browser.
So on YouTube in a little Embed,
you can click the Full
Screen and it goes full screen,
but there's been no
way to do that outside
of Flash or other
plug-in content so far.
So now we have a Full
Screen API.
This is implemented across
modern browsers these days.
So if we have let's say this
video element, we're going to
set up a little on-click
element, and this is the main
call right here, Request
Full Screen.
And this is just going to say,
I'd like to take this element
and go full screen with it.
So again, the beauty here is
that it doesn't just work on
videos or images, it
could work on an
entire section of Dom.
So I'll take this video and
I'll start playing it.
And so this is just like a Div
of sorts, and I'll just toggle
Full Screen.
And so we just take that entire
Div, we go full screen
with it, we get that little
notification pop-up.
And this is similar to the
presentation mode, if you've
ever done manually Full Screen
in Chrome, it's just that, but
we've now triggered it
with JavaScript.
So we can give our users this
option inside the app, instead
of asking someone to actually
go up here and hit that.
And the cool thing here is that
we also know if the user
is viewing inside Full
Screen, and we can
have contextual styling.
So this right here,
this is an iFrame.
And when I take this full
screen, I can actually detect
that it's now being shown in
that Full Screen mode, and I
can restyle it.
So here, it's a lame iFrame, but
when we go full screen, we
kind of crank it up a notch.
Pretty good.
I mean, it's kind of
ugly actually, but
you have the option.
OK, cool.
Pointer Lock API is another API
that is really exciting,
especially when it comes
to browser-based games.
I guess quickly, let's
say you're on a
multi-monitor system.
And if you want to run a game,
you're going to want to run it
full screen, like a first
person shooter.
And when you bring your cursor
to the edge because you like
looking left or looking right,
you don't want your cursor to
go on to the next monitor,
you want it to be
stuck there, right?
So the Pointer Lock API allows
you to kind of define, this is
the area in which
I'm operating.
So first, you take
it full screen.
And then now, my cursor
is totally hidden.
So the game can define its own
cursor if it wants, but you're
probably just going to use
this for movement.
And you can react, and you're
kind of stuck in full screen
until you want to get out of it,
which is the behavior that
you want when you're
building a game.
So this was another
partnership.
Some Google engineers got
together with some Mozilla
engineers, banged this spec out
in like the course of two
months, and it's implemented
across both now.
Another one that a gaming
community group got together
on was the Gamepad API, and I'll
just show this demo here.
So we're going to show this with
Firefox Nightly, but this
is available in Chrome
as well.
So we have, this is just a 2D
canvas game, and we're using
an Xbox USB controller, just
plugs right into the machine.
And essentially, Gamepad API
can track any sort of
adjustments to that control.
So whether it's like a joystick
with a lot of
precision, or just up/down or
x, y, a, b, triggers, all
those buttons are covered by
the Gamepad API so you can
enable a more rich input
method into your games.
All right.
Pause that and go forward.
Like I said, I think it's
important to be nice, and one
of the things being nice is
recognizing kind of the
context in which your users are
looking at your content.
Page Visibility API
lets you do that.
And so Page Visibility API
basically says, is the user
looking at this page?
So I'll show the demo first.
So cute little guy, HTML5
video, it's cool.
If you see at the very top where
we just wired it up so
that we count how many seconds
are passing by.
But if I switch tabs, now
it's immediately paused.
I go back, it continues.
So we're able to respond to
the fact that we know, the
user is not looking here, we
can change the behavior and
change the status.
I think if you're writing
an IM client, user is
idle, user is active.
User is idle, user is active,
or something.
You might also like, if you were
pulling the server for
new messages or something,
you're probably going to
throttle it back.
You don't need to be asking so
much because you know they're
not active, you know they're
not there, so you
have choices there.
Another similar one is
RequestAnimationFrame.
Animation And
RequestAnimationFrame is a
programmatic way of saying, I'm
going to be putting things
out, I'm going to be drawing
things to the screen.
But Browser, you probably know
what's best as far as
hardware, and so why don't you
take care how exactly to
schedule this?
So there's two good reasons
to use RAF,
RequestAnimationFrame.
So this is a blog post over
on the IE blog, they've
implemented this in IE 10.
So right here, it's showing
on this top.
Typically in animations,
you'll use either a set
timeout or a set interval and
just bang it against like 10
milliseconds.
Sorry, that's what
this one is.
Every 10 milliseconds, your app
is going to generate like
a new frame of the game and
try and send that out.
But a monitor like this monitor,
this one, they
refresh at 60 Hertz.
So you get a maximum of
60 frames per second.
And if we can make sure that
our game outputs a frame 60
times per second, so then we
can match and sync it up
directly with the time that that
monitor is refreshing,
that's ideal, right?
So RequestAnimationFrame
allows us to do this.
So we're just like, we got new
content, browser, you take
care of it.
And it will keep the
frame rate as
high fidelity as possible.
Otherwise, these red arrows
indicate that you're actually
missing frames.
You're generating all these
frames, and no one
ever even sees it.
The other good benefit is that
just like page visibility API,
RequestAnimationFrame knows
if you're looking at it.
So here we have a WebGL
Particles Demo.
Love particle demos,
always looks good.
Cool.
All right, so what I'm going to
do is as you can imagine,
this is probably a pretty
intense demo.
I'm going to bring up my Task
Manager in Chrome and move
that over a little bit more.
All right.
So in the Task Manager, we can
kind of see how much memory is
being consumed, the CPU.
This one over here is the number
of goats teleported,
I'm not sure why that's
in there, but it might
be useful to you.
But the thing that we're looking
at right here is the
CPU usage of Particles Morph.
Right now, it looks like
it's taking up
50%, a decent amount.
I'm going to switch back to the
other tab, and this figure
should drop.
Yes, OK.
So this is because the Particle
Morph demo is using
RequestAnimationFrame.
The browser's like hey, you're
not looking at it.
I don't need to even
send this out.
This way, my battery is being
conserved as much as possible,
which I like.
And then when I come back, I
know that it's syncing up
exactly with my Screen Refresh,
so I'm getting the
highest fidelity as possible.
Sweet.
A while ago when HTML5 was
getting a lot of attention,
there was a lot of focus on a
thing called the Device Tag.
And this is what you
think it is.
It's getting the actual camera
and microphone from your
machine and having that
as a first class
citizen in the browser.
That's been changed.
And so instead of the Device
Tag, it's now called
getUserMedia.
And this is essentially
how it works.
You have a video element
function,
and right over here--
see if I can get that,
it's somewhere--
is this S being passed
into this callback.
This S is a stream, and so
first, we're going to grab
this video element, and then
we're going to create an
object URL out of the stream
and set that as the
source of the video.
So this just means, get the
camera, get the microphone,
and just pipe it through
to this video.
So essentially, what this
looks like is this.
Yes.
All right, cool.
So here's this.
This is all built
with JavaScript.
Good.
I like that.
So I can apply CSS Filters,
which showed before, get a
nice effect on there.
And the guy who wrote this demo,
I asked him for this
feature a few days ago.
I think it'll work.
Sweet Polaroid effect where it
has to fade in, but if you
shake it-- yes?
Yeah!
So you can actually, I mean
you can use accelerometer
data, there's events that fire
in MacBook Pros to respond to
that, and you can be able to
say, in this case, I want to
speed up the rendering
of that.
But this is a really
great API, I'm very
happy to have it.
The thing I like about all these
APIs is that they mix up
and they mix well together.
So we're taking the video, and
now we're applying it frame by
frame to a 2D canvas, and that
means we can do something like
[EXPLOSION NOISE], or
just explode that
video any way we want.
We can apply any effect.
So in this one, we are taking
the video and now we're piping
it through to WebGL, because
we're going to do a little bit
more comprehensive changes.
So we can do stuff like this.
Anything you want.
Whoa.
I saw a Tweet other day, it was
like, "I don't care who
you are, but put you in front
of a camera doing these
effects, and you will turn into
a five-year-old." And
that is true.
OK.
I'm just going to move on.
I'll be there all day.
This brings us to WebRTC.
WebRTC is--
well, OK.
So you might be familiar with
things like, let's see, Google
Talk, G+ Hangouts,
the live video.
Live video's coming to
a lot of things.
You might be familiar with a
small little blue icon where
you video real time chat with
people over the internets.
Good thing.
Wouldn't it be nice if we had
it baked into the browser?
Yes.
Yes, it would be.
So WebRTC is an effort
for that.
So it's a plugin-free way for
doing real time voice and
video directly inside the
browser, having nice
JavaScript APIs so that we
can just wire it in.
The really cool thing about
this is that because the
browser is handling it, it can
add in a bunch of extra
functionality that would be
super hard for us as end
developers to deal with.
So like echo cancellation, noise
reduction if it's loud
in the back of the room, it's
like focusing on me, automatic
gain control to make sure that
I'm not too loud or too quiet.
If the network connection is
bad, like I'm on a slow
connection but the person I'm
talking to is on a fast
connection, it's just going to
work it out, make sure that
the fidelity of the video just
kind of scales regardless.
So there's a lot of good stuff
kind of baked into it.
And the cool thing is that
WebRTC is a cross-vendor
initiative led by Google, but
Mozilla and Opera are actively
working on it.
And so we have an implementation
in Google
Chrome now, but we're expecting
to see it in some of
these other browsers
pretty soon.
As far as how this works, it
is peer to peer, but you do
need to kind of handshake
through a server.
So this is the way that
it kicks off.
We set up a new peer connection
through this
server, this is like
the protocol.
And essentially, this should
look familiar.
We have a getUserMedia again,
where we're going to get our
video and our audio, set up the
stream, and hook that up.
So we're really excited about
this and think that not only
WebRTC but all these features
give you a lot of
functionality.
So I want you to think about
kind of the experiences that
this allows you to provide,
not just the features
themselves but combining them
together, because I think it
has some really good
potential.
A few resources that
I would recommend.
HTML5 Rocks is a Chrome
Developer relations site where
we just publish a lot
of this stuff.
It very much focuses on kind
of the edge of browser
development, so what are the
brand new things coming into
Chrome and other browsers, a lot
of very in-depth tutorials
as well, great content.
I'm really, really
happy with it.
Check that out.
HTML5 Please is a site that came
out recently, and it is
very much focused on like,
people that come to my sites
are real people with real
browsers and those browsers
might be a little old.
HTML5 Please is about making
recommendations to you based
on like, is it OK to implement
this thing, what is the fall
back story, can I
use a polyfill?
So basically, recommendations
from people who have been
there before on the right way
to handle every feature.
And HTML5-demos is another site
where you'll find slide
decks like this one and a lot of
other demos as well, so I'd
recommend that out.
There are two sites.
One is HTML5-demos,
one is HTML5demos.
Different sites, both good.
And that's it for me.
These slides are available at
this case sensitive link that
you're welcome to write
down or something.
It's not very friendly, I'm
sorry, sorry, sorry.
But Yeah.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So it looks
like we've got about 15
minutes for questions.
So there's plenty of time.
So if anybody has a question
for this gentleman here,
please shout it out.
MALE SPEAKER: Does Pointer Lock
only work in Full Screen?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So the question
for the internet
audience was, does the Pointer
Lock only work in Full Screen?
PAUL IRISH: You know, I was
curious about this as well.
I'm not sure.
So I believe it does.
No.
It totally works outside
of full screen.
I'm not sure.
This is the page.
Luckily, MDN, Google has
actually been contributing to
MDN recently, and so
I think, yeah, we
contributed this page.
And so in lot of cases, the
MDN actually has quite
up-to-date information, on not
only what the compatibility
story is and what browsers this
is available in, but also
how to use it.
So check that out.
Sir?
MALE SPEAKER: Is the video
[INAUDIBLE] just peer-to-peer,
or could you do group
stuff, group chats?
PAUL IRISH: Is the video stuff
peer-to-peer or can you do
group stuff?
So WebRTC, it can totally
be group.
You just need the server to
set up the handshakes, but
from there on, it can totally
go scale to a group.
Very cool.
MALE SPEAKER: Can you
stream video only
by server with WebRTC?
PAUL IRISH: Can you
stream video--
MALE SPEAKER: Only through
the server?
PAUL IRISH: Through
MALE SPEAKER: Just to
the server, though.
Not to another peer.
PAUL IRISH: Ah, so you're saying
you want to do that,
but without going directly
peer-to-peer?
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
PAUL IRISH: Ah, OK.
It's a good question.
MALE SPEAKER: Can you repeat
that question?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, so the
question is, can you use
WebRTC without going just
peer-to-peer and instead proxy
it through a server?
So yeah.
I haven't done it, but I don't
see any reason why you can't
just set up your pure connection
essentially to the
server instead.
Yeah, I mean you could totally
manage that at the server
level and just pass
the connection
right through to itself.
So yeah.
Yeah?
MALE SPEAKER: What kind of API
is it to kind of map what
buttons people are pressing on
the Gamepad controller to like
actual [INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So this is a tough one.
Let's see, Rob Hawkes Gamepad.
Rob did an excellent
post recently.
I don't know if I'm going
to be able to find this.
Also look [INAUDIBLE] can bring
up this site right now.
Please?
Yes.
Gamepad, yeah.
OK, I can't find
this other one.
So basically right now, with the
Gamepad API, is it returns
to you what the configuration
is, the model, the
configuration, of the actual
controller, and then it
numbers all the inputs from
one to 30 or something and
then says that input
12 is now reporting
this stream of events.
There's two JavaScript libraries
that try and work
out differences between
controllers.
One of them is Gamepad JS, and
this is actually made by
Scott, who is the engineer
who built the Gamepad
implementation for Chrome.
So it's a good guy to build the
JavaScript library for it.
So yeah, it tries to smooth
over the differences.
So with different Gamepads, you
will get kind of different
mappings, and so you essentially
need a dictionary
to look up like this
to normalize.
They're trying to figure out a
better way to handle that, but
right now, you're essentially
looking at
one of these libraries.
But these are well-tested and
kind of where the entire
community is focusing its
effort, so it's a good set-up
to have.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: More
questions?
MALE SPEAKER: Does that
CSS drop shadow
work with alpha channels?
PAUL IRISH: Work with
alpha changes?
MALE SPEAKER: Alpha channels.
PAUL IRISH: Channels?
Like you have an alpha
channel on--
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: Ah.
Well, hm.
MALE SPEAKER: Because like,
what's the point of
[INAUDIBLE] drop shadow,
[INAUDIBLE]?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, there's a very
large debate regarding
the sorts of shadows that are
available, and if I have like
an SVG shape or some
non-rectangle, if I have--
not text.
Text has its own shadow.
Yeah, so there's been a big--
so I can't cut out a
circle out of this
unless I used Clip.
No, clip wouldn't work.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
PNG would not work.
So the filter is actually,
let's see, FXTF filters.
So the spec actually comes
over here from the Filter
Effects cross-functional group,
and this is basically a
collaboration of people who have
been working on SVG, and
then people in CSS land.
And so all the filters, while
I was showing kind of the
shorthand filters of these guys,
it actually takes in a
lot of these primitives.
Those are just shorthand for
mixing up the filter
primitives, and all of these
come directly from SVG.
And because they come
from SVG, SVG is all
about custom shapes.
And so while I can't bring up
a demo that uses a custom
shape in these filters, I have
no doubt that it works.
We also, there is hardware
acceleration for--
I think we landed full hardware
acceleration for all
these filters in Canary.
So that just means they're
faster, which is a good thing.
Quick question on--
it seems like you guys
have implemented
everything that Flash did.
Is there anything left?
I feel like you guys--
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
Good question.
You know, I was curious
about this as well.
What is left?
There are a lot of wishes.
I think part of is building
on top of things.
We just finished off Mutation
Observers, which is
essentially an iteration on
Mutation Events, but they're
far, far more performing.
So with Mutation Events, you
would subscribe to like DOM
sub-tree modified, and it would
tell you if anything in
the DOM had changed.
People use this all the time
for Chrome extensions, for
Grease Monkey scripts, when
you're hooking into a third
party web page and you want to
know if somebody clicked the
New Tweet button because you're
going to add some part
of the UI to it, but
things are very not
performing at all.
Mutation Observers are a better
way of tracking these
changes, and it's like
500 times more
performing than the other.
So in some cases, it's
things like that.
Other cases, I've heard, I want
Photoshop's Blend modes,
like Darker and Multiply
against DOM.
So like this DIV, I want to
multiply against this other
DIV. Filters might get us
part of the way there.
But yeah, there's a lot coming
in CSS in particular that I'm
happy about.
So like CSS as a language
is limited.
Mix-ins, so things that you
might be familiar with from
Sass and LESS and the other
preprocessors of variables,
mix-ins, selector nesting.
There's specs for all these
things, and some of it's
starting to land in Canary.
So CSS variables
in particular.
We do have a spec for
it that [INAUDIBLE]
Atkins, who's actually here at
South By, is working on.
Here it is.
And our engineering team is
actually implementing this
like as we speak.
So we're going to be expecting
to see some of this stuff just
happening for real,
and I'm excited,
especially in the CSS land.
Layout, we have grid layout,
the brand new Flex Box, the
Regions that I showed.
And I would expect the DOM
to be better as well.
Right now, the DOM, like people
use jQuery because DOM
APIs are annoying.
And I hope we're going
to see that improve.
There's lot of people that want
to make that better, make
that more performant.
Any other questions?
No?
Cool.
Well again, HTML5 Rocks,
good stuff.
And if you have any more
questions, feel free to Tweet
at me or hit be on G+.
I do post a lot of really cool
stuff about HTML5 stuff,
Chrome Dev tools, on Google+,
try and link it up via Twitter
when I can.
So good things, check
that out.
So thank you guys,
appreciate it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank
you, Paul.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right, and
coming up to the stage, we
have both Josh and Chris, and
they're going to be talking
about making your maps beautiful
and interactive.
I'd also like to remind you, if
you want to see this after
we're done today, we're
recording this whole thing and
it's going to be available on
the Google Developers' YouTube
channel page.
So you can just do a quick
search for that and get all of
these sessions on video
at home later.
Maybe there's something you
missed, or you wanted an
instant replay of one
of Paul's slides.
You can get all that.
JOSH LIVNI: [INAUDIBLE] like
a couple minutes here
for people to settle?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
we'll give you a
couple minutes to settle.
We do have this one last
session about maps.
If you're in the back and you'd
like a seat, we have
some lovely seats up here.
They're green, they're
triangular, and they make me
feel a little bit like I'm
in elementary school.
You see these chairs?
These are cool.
A little desk would be great,
but you see how they have the
hole in the back?
Remember that from school?
I don't know why that
hole's there.
MALE SPEAKER: Gum.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you can put
the gum through there?
So yeah, please do come
on up and grab a seat.
We do have some more
seats available.
And why don't you guys go
ahead and take it away?
JOSH LIVNI: All right.
I'm going to make
a run for it.
Sorry for this noise that's
about to happen.
Made it!
We have some speaker effect.
All right.
Should we get started?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
let's get started.
JOSH LIVNI: OK.
Hi, everybody.
So my name is Josh.
This is Chris.
We're on the Maps Developer
Relations Team.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: We're going to
talk today about beautiful
maps, so making your geographic
information
beautiful and interactive.
And so we're going to be showing
some cool things we've
been working on, various Google
APIs, a whole bunch of
awesome HTML5 stuff.
So let's give a bit of
context to this talk.
JOSH LIVNI: Yep, here we have
a very early map, Mayan.
There's a lot of things you
notice about it, a little
different from the
modern web maps.
It's smaller, it has a
legend at the top.
It has none of the HTML5 stuff
that Paul was going over.
And our intent is to try to fix
some of these things in
future slides, but it's good
to see where maps started.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Not
very interactive.
JOSH LIVNI: Not very.
So here we get a little
bit interactive.
This is about 15 years ago,
state of the art GIS system.
Lots of data, people starting
to make kind of these
interactive maps where
you could toggle
lots of check boxes.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: The sad thing
here is you have to press
radio buttons to navigate
the world.
JOSH LIVNI: And press Redraw
to redraw it, and each map
tile is dynamically done
for you custom.
But it was a bit slow, not
super user-friendly.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Unfortunately,
some people
still make maps like this.
JOSH LIVNI: Yes, they do.
So things got better.
We got all the important
countries on an
early Google Map.
The key here is we pre-rendered
the tiles in
advance, and so we came up with
this idea of the slippy
map, where you could call around
and everything's kind
of instantaneous feeling
and just really
dynamic, nice feel.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So you're not
loading everything as you try
to look around.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
So it's not super custom, we've
decided in advance what
the look and feel is, but
you get this really nice
interaction.
So this is kind of the start of
the new age of interactive
maps, not that long ago.
Here we've added some more
countries and some more data,
and tons and tons of stuff
on these map tiles.
So these map tiles seem like
they're pre-rendered, but
actually, there's a lot of
interesting customizations you
can do with them when you go to
the Google Maps, and that's
what we're going to take
a look at here.
Little did you know, perhaps.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So this
is Styled Maps.
This was launched at
Google I/O in 2010.
And so it basically allows you
to change the colors and
display of all the
map features.
So here we've got our beautiful
landscape is black,
roads as pink.
This is one of my favorite
styles, by the way.
JOSH LIVNI: He's a professional
cartographer.
That's why we hired him.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: That's right.
JOSH LIVNI: But you switch back
and forth between the map
and the other version there.
And you can see that what we're
actually doing is we're
rendering these tiles
dynamically for any style that
you want to have. Maybe show
them the label style.
And the idea-- oh, go ahead.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: This is one
of my favorite maps.
It's a map without a
map, just labels.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, you
zoom in and out?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Just
an experiment.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, and so the
idea here is we can provide a
really custom experience
for you.
But again, this is
not your data.
It's a backdrop you can
use to tell your
story with your data.
So be sure you always customize
the background and
that your sort of pre-tiled
images are telling
the story you want.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So you
can use this to
bring your data alive.
So if you're displaying stuff
on a Google Map, you might
want to remove roads if they're
not so important for
your data, it's really cool.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
Our base map is really designed,
the story we're
trying to tell, which may not be
the exact same story you're
trying to tell, like where all
the freeways are, or where all
the public transit.
Anyway, let's get to
your data, which is
what the talk's about.
So here's a bunch of trees
mapped in San Francisco, a
couple hundred thousand trees.
There's lots of it, and this is,
I guess, green dot fever,
a variety of the red dot fever
that comes around when you're
trying to, man, I have
a lot of data.
How am I going to put
it on the map?
And the classic way of doing
this, since browsers until
very recently could only handle
maybe a few hundred, a
few thousand points, is I'm
going to have to take this
data, put it on a server, render
up my own tiles, and
overlay those tiles
on top of the map.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's
pretty hard.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's
a lot of work.
JOSH LIVNI: There's a big stack
of things you have to
take care of and think about.
We have some tools to make this
easy, but this is kind of
what you're seeing here.
These are rendered tiles, and
then we just display these
PNGs on top of the map.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Made with
the map, of course.
JOSH LIVNI: You can click on
them and get some information
back, kind of makes a call to
the server and says what's
here, and here's a tree and
a species and whatnot.
But your interaction's
limited.
And again, you sort of have to
get it all through this work
flow of rendering tiles.
So what if you could actually
just use JavaScript to put
your data on top of the map?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So this is one
of the solutions to this
big data problem.
It's called clustering.
Unfortunately, it scales only up
to maybe tens of thousands
of points, something
like that.
It's quite pretty.
JOSH LIVNI: And we can't display
all 10,000 either, so
we've got to only display
a few hundred at a time.
Here's there's much
less than that.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: You sort of get
sort of a cheap heat map.
So you sort of get a sense of
where all the points are.
JOSH LIVNI: Now, there's some
stories that this is actually
conducive to.
So it's actually sometimes great
to do a Marker Clusterer
for certain types of stories.
But it's just important to
remember the inherent
limitation here is, we can't be
displaying a million points
in JavaScript on the browser.
So this is one of the techniques
to get around that.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: As you said, I
mean, get individual points,
so you can click on them,
whatever you want.
JOSH LIVNI: So keep in mind, the
Marker Clusterer, you have
a bunch, a few thousand points,
you want to display
them on the map.
And then we should look at what
the future holds, or the
current now.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So this an
experiment I did it would have
been a few months ago now, just
to see how many points I
could throw at the browser.
So these are 10,000 crimes
in San Francisco
over a one-month period.
JOSH LIVNI: A very safe city.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And I decided,
I just want to render
all these and see the places
I should avoid when I'm
visiting the city.
So I'm coloring different
types of crime
with different colors.
And as they are drawn on top of
each other, they stack up,
so you can sort of see hot
spots of crime activity.
JOSH LIVNI: And the important
bit here is instead of
rendering these as tiles in an
overlay, we're just throwing
all the vector data down to
the browser, the browser's
displaying these using canvas.
So finally, HTML5 has arrived.
Canvas.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So as I zoom
in, I just keep rendering.
JOSH LIVNI: OK, all right.
So here is a bit of
a morbid map.
This is the last seven to 10
years of traffic fatalities in
the United States.
We're looking at about-- go
ahead and type "fatals" into
the box there, and maybe
zoom in somewhere.
What we're looking at here is
about, I think, 300,000
accidents or so.
Maybe just--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: 2,000.
JOSH LIVNI: 278,000.
And if you zoom in somewhere
else, there's a couple
interesting things to note.
Maybe zoom into Austin.
There we go.
So here's a bunch of points, and
what you can see is about
700 accidents or so.
Move the slider, the
size of the slider.
One of the things you'll notice
as you zoom in and out,
you can change it to a really
gruesome-looking map with a
lot of accidents, or maybe
something a little more
subtle, you're trying to get
a different point across.
We can style them according to
different colors, and I'm kind
of contradicting what I said,
you can't get a lot
of points in here.
And what we're doing here is
we're using WebGL to render,
in the graphics shader, a
lot and a lot of data.
We can render a significant
amount.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Millions.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah,
many millions.
It's pretty exciting, it's kind
of a new world where we
can send the vector data over,
and actually render these in
the browser, and actually start
to run different types
of analysis or filtering.
So a really simple example,
go ahead and
hit that filter there.
You've probably heard
most accidents
happen close to home.
So I've just got a filter that
runs on the distance between
where the accident occurred and
where that car driver is
registered.
So you can see as you drag it
on the way up to 100, say,
most of the accidents go away.
Most people's accidents occur
within less than 100
kilometers, 60 miles or
so, of their house.
So maybe zoom out
to Florida, say.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I don't
know where that is.
JOSH LIVNI: There it
is in bottom right.
So we have this Place API drop
down for people like this.
It's pretty good.
You just type in whatever you
want, it takes you there.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Whoa.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
So you can see there's a lot
of accidents that happened.
It's crazy--
more than 100 miles away from
home, probably a lot of people
there as tourists.
So you can kind of get an idea,
here's a tourist spot,
everyone goes there,
has an accident.
The locals still have a lot of
accidents, but there's still
plenty left for that.
Whereas you go to a city say
Sacramento, San Francisco, and
you drag that away, you'll see
almost all of the accidents--
maybe try, or Austin--
most of the accidents happen.
Where did they go?
Make it a little bigger.
Maybe that data didn't load.
Interesting.
There we go.
So anyway, you get the general
idea here, which is I can
throw a lot of points, do cool
techniques kind of like Paul
was showing, animate these,
filter them, style them based
on some attributes, and at about
60 frames a second, get
some pretty dynamic results.
So let's scoot over to
quick example using
the exact same stack.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's
a very bloody map.
JOSH LIVNI: Not accidents.
This is just census blocks sized
by population, it's a
little bit better.
So if you zoom out here, just
a couple zoom-outs, you can
see I've got millions
of census blocks
here, that's good.
And you can drag the
filter if you want.
And not especially amazing map,
except to show off I can
display millions and millions
of points in WebGL on top of
the map pretty easily, and this
is being run through App
Engine to CloudSQL.
So no special spatial database
or anything, just toss it into
MySQL, stream it over in binary
format directly to the
graphics card, and then I can
work with this in JavaScript
to style and do analysis.
So pretty cool stuff when you
have really big data that you
want to have an interactive
feel with.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, on
the topic of big data--
I say data, actually.
So this is a data set that I've
been playing around with
for the last few weeks.
It's really awesome.
You should check it out if
you're interested in
this kind of stuff.
It's 25,000 cab trips
in the San Francisco
area over a week period.
So you've got here the cab ID,
the time, and the location of
the cab at that time.
So the cab ID's useful because
you can string together a
whole bunch of these points and
figure out the path of a
particular cab.
So this equates to over
one million points.
So similar in vain to Josh's
visualization, we can just
display them all at once.
So of course all of these
points, one million points all
stacked on top of each other
doesn't look great.
So each point, I've got a very
small amount of opacity, so
they sort of stack up.
And you can immediately see
the most-traveled streets.
So just for a moment, imagine
that the base map wasn't here,
you'd sort of be able to get a
sense of the layout of the San
Francisco city, which
is pretty cool, just
from this raw data.
And then we can do something
like take a
selection of that data.
So here I'm taking
a slice of time.
So from 4:00 PM on Sunday to
4:08, and you can just see the
trail of that particular car.
JOSH LIVNI: Can you zoom it
in a bit there, yeah.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So this is sort
of interesting, but you
can't get a sense of the
direction that the car is
traveling in.
So we can apply some techniques,
color and scale,
to sort of show a trail behind
the cab's current position at
the end of that time slice.
This is sort of cool.
You get a sense of direction.
And then we can do some really
cool things like animate
through, and you really
get a sense of
the flow of the traffic.
So just by moving the slice
of time slowly--
so we're doing about five
minutes of time every second,
something like that--
you sort of get a
sense of flow.
And if I did this through the
whole data set, you'd cycle
through the days of the week
and be able to see the busy
and the quiet periods.
That's sort of cool, but let's
do some more interesting
things, such as coloring.
So here I've applied a color
to each point, and it's the
speed of the car at that
point in time.
So I've used the cab ID to
figure out where it's been
traveling, the speed.
And so this is sort of cool.
Just by plotting all these
points, you get a sense of
where the traffic
in the city is.
And if I just zoom in, it sort
of fades out, and we can
provide a tool like this to sort
of bump up the opacity,
so you can really start to
explore the data set.
And so the interesting thing
that you might see here is
that around the Market Street
area downtown, the GPS is
really noisy.
So you can sort of see, as
opposed to really straight
streets, you've got all this
sort of fuzzy points.
JOSH LIVNI: Tall buildings
are not good for GPS.
[INAUDIBLE].
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
apparently cars can't drive
through buildings.
So we can combine these
techniques to sort of get a
colored squiggle moving around
the screen, which I thought
was pretty cool.
When I first did this, I sort
of just animated through it
and stared at it for five
minutes, as I will do now for
five minutes.
MALE SPEAKER: Can you talk a
little bit about what your
data set actually looks
like to power that?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, sure.
Let's just look at the next
thing first. So this is a
one-hour slice of time.
And this is great, because you
can just scroll through and
get a sense of the traffic
flows in that hour.
So you see, it gets really quiet
around four AM, and as I
keep scrolling through, you sort
of see the sort of more
macro level of the flows of
traffic throughout the week.
And it gets really busy
on Friday night.
And you can see that traffic
starts to get pretty bad
around 5:00 PM, you notice
people are heading out to
dinner and whatnot.
And then Saturday night gets
really busy again.
And you can do cool things like,
if we just go ahead and
display the whole data set,
we can go and zoom in.
So this area looks
a bit funny.
So it's sort of
interesting-looking for these
red areas where cars
tend to stop.
And so another cool one's down
here near the airport, some
sort of waiting bay or
something like that.
Sort of cool.
And this is really awesome,
because you can zoom down into
a particular point, which
is sort of amazing.
JOSH LIVNI: Let's hop back to
that data set to the guy's
question, because what I think
is so incredible about this is
it's really just some straight
GPS lat-long times, and then
from throwing it out directly at
the browser, we can create
these pretty incredible,
dynamic, interactive tools,
rather than having to render
some preset tiles in advance,
and here's the story,
here's the map--
which is great and fine, but
you can really start
to play with it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: The other thing
we didn't mention was
we're using technologies like
Web Sockets to stream
some the data down.
So like for the example where
I showed a small slice of
time, you can stream just that
data down to the client, they
can start looking at it in
hundreds of milliseconds as
opposed to loading the
full data set.
Yeah, it's kind of cool.
Or you could load just some
portion of the map that
they're looking at, something
like that.
JOSH LIVNI: You want to
show the heat map?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So another visualization of this
data set, basically just
a heat map.
So a heat map's really
an intensity map.
So we can see the most-traveled
roads, which are
in red, and it sort of
fades out to blue.
And all of this being rendered
using WebGL as well, so it's
quite fast. We've got 500,000
points here, I've just taken
half of the data set.
And you sort of see this really
blurry area around
Market Street again, which
is interesting.
But this is a really good way
to see the most frequently
traveled roads.
And you sort of get a sense of
where they're stopping for
traffic lights and taking off,
you sort of see a sort of
triangle pattern at
intersections, which I think
is interesting.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
And I think again, the main
story here is the problems
that used to be really hard--
displaying a heat map, you had
to set up all this
infrastructure, you had to get
your points on top of the
geospatial database, you had
to render some tiles, and
then boom, you have
a static heat map.
Now we can just get the raw data
and let users sort of see
the story that they
want to see.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: You can start
to explore and look at what
you want to look at.
JOSH LIVNI: So I
think that's--
oh yeah.
What should you do if
you would like to do
this type of thing?
So to kind of start out
at the beginning here,
just a quick recap.
Not all the way to Mayan style,
but if you want to
start using some techniques to
make pretty maps, use our
Styled Maps, makes your
backgrounds, like you noticed
in these demos, a nice, faded
background lets you tell your
story nicely on top.
Maybe the story you have to
tell, you want some really
vibrant colors, use
that beautiful
example Chris put together.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I have a sweet
video of a Christmas
styled map, all green and red
and white, it's pretty sweet.
JOSH LIVNI: You can imagine how
pretty that would look.
Yeah, so the Style Map's really
good, use that for the
background.
You've got some couple thousand
points, maybe you
want to cluster them, it's a
good technique, depending on
the different stories you have.
Dotter, at Open Source
Library, you can look for.
That's just a canvas
[INAUDIBLE], so a lot of
computers don't have WebGL
ready, maybe want to display a
few tens of thousands of points,
you get that in a nice
canvas, it's widely supported
and looks pretty good.
Put your data up on some App
Engine, CloudSQL type of thing
if you want, and then just
stream it down with web
sockets or what have you.
You've got all the HTML5
stuff we covered.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So all of those
links are down at that
goo.gl short link, which will
also be on the next slide.
Thanks for coming.
JOSH LIVNI: All right.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And
drive safely.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, yeah.
Indeed.
So it looks like we
have about five,
seven minutes for questions?
Is that right, Timothy?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You do have
time for questions.
JOSH LIVNI: That's what
I like to hear.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How
many can we get?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I can
always rely on
this guy for a question.
JOSH LIVNI: Uh oh.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, cool.
You mentioned kind of briefly
the limit between SVG and when
you started using WebGL.
I'd like to know more about
where that limit actually is,
and then maybe even what, if
any, is the upper limit of
WebGL for the number of
points you can show.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yes.
So we actually didn't do
anything with SVG, and I
haven't done much work with SVG,
but I think for this kind
of work, Canvas 2D is faster.
JOSH LIVNI: You tend to notice
a bit of a panning delay on
the Redraw when you're working
with SVG, so it kind of
renders quickly and you have
instant CSS action on it,
which is great, but it has some
other drawbacks, and we
kind of prefer going with
the Canvas route.
But really important question,
which is how far can you get?
5,000, 10,000, 15,000, on
Canvas, and it really is up
the person and their browser.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And
their computer.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, exactly.
So most modern browsers, you
could get 20,000 points, no
problem probably on Canvas.
But maybe an older browser,
you'd have some--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So we actually
render Google Map
Markers in Canvas, and we sort
of say tens of thousands on
modern browsers and on
non-modern, like thousands,
something like that.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
And that's really kind of the
same for WebGL, depends a
bunch on your hardware,
on your graphics card.
The main limiting factor we've
noticed in WebGL is the
bottleneck is kind of
the bandwidth to get
all the data over.
And there's some interesting
things we're thinking
about to make that.
So I didn't really show you this
part, but for example in
the fatality demo, there's
thousands of attributes that
you can get all these
tables adjoined.
A really simple API, you just
get only those attributes that
I want and then bring
those ones over.
And so there's some techniques
you can use to overcome that
bottleneck, and the Web
Socket is just getting
the subset you want.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So even though
you can bring big data
into the client, you might
not necessarily want
to take all of it.
There's definitely a case
for taking slices of it.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah but definitely,
a million plus
points we've been showing,
and pretty
snappy, no problem here.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Heat maps
are pretty intensive
to generate as well.
So it's cool stuff.
Yep, down here?
MALE SPEAKER: I was just
wondering if the API will
include a fallback for less
modern browsers for those
features, like for
WebGL and Canvas?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Right.
So everything we've shown here
isn't in the API itself, it's
just sort of our experiments.
JOSH LIVNI: So as a developer,
you would potentially check to
see if the person had WebGL,
if so, give them one
experience, and kind of have
your own series of fall-backs,
a pretty good technique
to have generally.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
JOSH LIVNI: Yes, exactly.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So maybe if
they don't have WebGL, you
don't have these cool sliders,
you just give them the tiles
to look at.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Additional
questions?
MALE SPEAKER: This might be a
little bit of a segue, but so
I saw you guys did a lot of
stuff on the map itself, but
one of the pain points that
I found is the map bubble.
Were there any developments made
in making it easier for
developers to customize
the map bubble itself?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
There's a couple Open Source
libraries that sort of
re-implement a nice-looking
bubble.
Info Bubble's one of them
that's really, really
customizable.
You can use CSS to style it.
Yeah, check that out.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: More
questions?
No?
Is that it?
All right.
Is there anything else you guys
want to say before we go?
JOSH LIVNI: No.
We'll be around here for a
little while if you want to
come up and chat.
Drive home safe, and
play with WebGL.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
So just a few announcements for
you before we get going.
Thank you, of course, to all
of our speakers for the
excellent material that
they presented.
I'd also like to thank NewTek
for bringing in that really
cool tri-caster rig and
making our web stream
look absolutely fantastic.
We do have a hot dog
cart out front.
So if you're hungry, please
do grab some food.
We also have--
what's that?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Sorry
to the live stream.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, sorry
No hot dogs for you.
We do have code labs later
today, so please be sure to
check out that event's URL.
Just search for South by
Southwest Google, and you'll
get to our events URL with
speakers, where we're speaking
all around South By.
And also, come back for
these code labs.
It's a really great chance
to get sort of one-on-one
attention to do some cool
stuff with the APIs.
And those are at 3:00
PM in this house.
Anything else?
I have cue cards.
They're human cue cards.
It's really great.
But thank you so much and have
a great time at South By, and
do try and stay dry.
Bye now.